Four,
three,
two,
one,
boom.
And we're live 12 rules for life.
So without reading this.
So what you're saying is sort of like
there's only 12 things you need to know
in life,
right?
That's it.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah.
This,
um,
this interview that you just did with
this woman cathy new mission,
was that in the UK?
It was channel four UK.
Um,
I just went,
I felt bad,
but I was also laughing.
I went to her twitter page to read like
an in with each one of her tweets.
No matter what she says someone writes
underneath it.
So what you're saying is,
and then some ridiculous,
but by the way,
the,
your fans were mocking her but politely,
non aggressively their idea.
I didn't read any rude things like there
was no,
there was no insults or maybe a few
insults,
but there's no swears.
It was just playful mocking of the
interview that she did with you because
the interview was ridiculous.
It was a ridiculous interview.
I mean,
I listened to it or watched it several
times.
I was like,
this is so strange.
It's like her determination to turn it
into a conflict to.
It's one of the issues that I have with
television shows because they have a
very limited amount of time and they're
trying to make things as salacious as
possible.
They want to have these soundbites,
these clickbait sound soundbites and she
just went into it incredibly
confrontational.
Not Trying to find your actual
perspective but trying to force you to
defend a non non unrealistic
perspective.
Yes.
While I was at,
I was the hypothetical villain of her
imagination essentially.
Well what happened?
What was interesting too,
the way it played itself out,
because I met her in the greenroom
beforehand,
you know,
she was being made up and then they put
a little bit of powder on me and we had
a friendly kind of interchange and then
we went and sat in front of the cameras
for a couple of minutes before,
before the show got rolling and we had a
pretty pleasant back and forth and then
as soon as the cameras went on,
she was a completely different person
and I thought,
oh,
I see.
I see what's going on.
Yeah.
Well,
so,
so that kind of alerted me to,
well the fact that there was something
rotten in the state of Denmark,
let's say.
Yeah,
but you know,
this is also why Youtube is going to
kill tv because television by its
nature,
all of these narrow broadcast
technologies,
they re,
they rely on forcing the story,
right?
Because it has to happen now.
It has to happen in like often in five
minutes because they only broadcast five
minutes of that interview.
They did put the whole thing up on
youtube.
To their credit.
Yeah,
it,
it hasn't ceased to amaze me yet.
I think that they thought that the
interview went fine.
So that's the Scuttlebutt I've got from
sort of behind the scenes because I've,
you know,
I know some people who know what's going
on at channel four and they're shell
shocked by the response,
you know?
And,
and then of course there is the counter
to the Guardian.
The next day published a paper,
published an article saying that,
you know,
the head of channel four had to call in
police security because of threats,
you know.
Well,
first of all,
you can call the police and about
anything and they never did detail out
exactly what the threats were,
you know,
but then about 20 newspapers pick that
up and went for the.
Well,
Kathy Newman is now I'm being harassed
by an army of online trolls for doing
nothing but doing her job,
which.
Well,
and then there was a backlash against
that in the press.
So it's been a.
well,
when you say took an audit of the,
the actual interchanges between fans and
her and there was way more negative ones
coming your way?
Yes.
That were seriously negative.
Yeah.
That's seriously negative.
Violent,
harassing.
Just rude the way more.
Yep.
And no one picked up on that at all.
It has all the narrative was she's a
victim even though she was highly
aggressive,
but funny victim.
It's not like she's not successful.
At some point you think you should have
to hand in your victim card.
I think like when you go to an ivy
league university,
it's like right then and there you got
it handy because you don't get to be
oppressor and oppressed at the same
time.
That's just too much.
Well,
one of the things that you pointed out
was when you were talking about
competition for very lucrative jobs and
you were saying,
look what you've done like you,
you must have had to work here,
and she proudly was saying how hard she
had to work to get there.
I'm like,
well yes,
of course.
No one's gonna hand this to,
you know,
this is why,
and this is why you were saying you are
opposed to equality of outcome.
They'll come,
I can't imagine anything we could
possibly strive for in our society that
would make it into hell faster than
equality of outcome.
Like the historical,
the historical evidence for the
pathology of that root is so strong.
It's like you have to be historically
ignorant beyond belief or malevolent or
resentful beyond comprehension.
In order to think that that's a good
idea to argue for that.
I agree with you,
but I think that even if you came into
this with no knowledge of history but a
complete understanding of human beings,
you would say,
well,
that doesn't make any sense and one of
the best quotes that I've ever read
about it is that if you have real,
true freedom,
you're never going to have equality of
outcome because with real,
true freedom,
you have the freedom to not conduct age.
Well,
look,
if you look at a guy like Jeff Bezos,
for instance at Amazon,
guy was worth more money than anybody
ever.
Right?
That guy works all day.
Yeah,
I mean he's a maniac,
acquiring all these different companies
and everything he's doing is designed to
succeed.
I mean,
he's just
in a recent interview and I know some
guys that are there in approximately the
same universe as those two and they just
work all the time.
That's all they do and they don't just
work.
They work so efficiently and so
effectively and make use of every second
in ways you can't even imagine unless
you're in that sort of position.
So you know,
doing that doesn't mean that you will
succeed but not doing it certainly means
that you will fail,
you will use,
will not doing.
It certainly means you will never
achieve that level of success.
And that's what we're talking about.
We're talking about equality of outcome.
I don't want that.
I don't want to be that guy.
I don't want to work like that.
I don't want to do what he's doing and I
should have the freedom to not do that
as he should have the freedom to do
that.
If we're going to play this game called
capitalism,
which we're all agreeing is probably,
at least in as far as the models that we
have right now is the best one that we
have.
If we're all going to play this game,
if someone decides to be the Michael
Jordan of capitalism,
you can't stop them.
You can't say no,
no,
no.
You're playing this game too.
Well,
you're playing this team too hard.
You're too obsessed with this game.
You're going to have that.
Yeah,
you can stop them.
You can try to stop people from winning
crookedly yeah.
Which is what you should do and you know
there's a couple of things that are
really worth delving into with regards
to that too because there's this sort of
Marxist notion that all this inequality
is generated as a consequence of
capitalism and now it's actually
technically false because if you look at
there's a.
There seems to be something like a law
of nature that's described by this
statistical model called Prieto
distribution and it basically suggests
that in any creative domain there's
going to be a small number of people
will,
will do almost all of the output,
but it doesn't just apply to human
beings.
It implies it applies to the heights of
trees in the Amazon rain forest.
It applies to the size of cities and it
applies to the massive stars,
which is something like the more you
have,
the more you get.
It's something you can imagine how that
would work with his star.
As it gets bigger and bigger and its
gravitational mass increases,
it's going to attract more and more
matter.
And then as the city grows,
while more and more people are excited
to move there because of all the
opportunities,
and so some cities start to grow
tremendously and others and others
don't.
But this,
this,
this phenomena where a small number of
people end up controlling a tremendous
proportion of the resource is not only
limited to money and it doesn't only
occur in capitalist societies,
it occurs everywhere.
It's like a natural law.
So you see the same thing with number of
points scored by a,
you know,
a spectacular sports figure.
It was always a tiny proportion of
people who are way,
way ahead way ahead on the curve or
people who make records or people who
sell paintings or people who compose
music or people who sell music online.
It's all the same.
It's,
it's the one percent gets 80 percent and
so.
Well first we can't blame that on
capitalism.
And second we should note that it
actually does constitute a problem,
which is what the left wingers are
always jumping up and down about,
right?
Too much inequality starts to
destabilize your society and it isn't
obvious how to shovel money from the top
and maybe the one 10th of one percent
who have almost all the money down to
the people who have almost nothing in a
way that's effective so that they don't
get thrown out of the game completely
and so that the whole society doesn't
destabilize.
We don't exactly know how to do that.
It is a problem because inequality does
exist and it does tend to magnify across
time.
And then there's another problem too,
which we haven't figured out,
is imagine that in order to make
everyone rich,
you have to tolerate a certain amount of
inequality.
That seems obvious.
We don't know how many units of
inequality you need to tolerate per unit
of wealth generated,
but the answer is definitely not zero.
It's definitely not zero.
So
yeah,
so it goes back to this equality of
outcome idea.
Yeah.
And this,
this thing has perplexed me since I've
met you and since you were involved in
this original debate over gender
pronouns,
and there was an article that was
written recently,
I forget the exact title of it is,
I think it was something along the lines
of why can people hear what Jordan
Peterson saying?
You are misrepresented more than anyone
I know you know weird way.
You are villainized in a weird way where
I can't believe that these people are
honestly looking at your opinions and
coming up with these conclusions.
I I can't help but feel like what is
happening is people are consciously
deciding to ignore reality and paint you
as this archetype will figure of
oppressive white male patriarchy,
ignorance to fill in the blank with all
the rest of the descriptives that you'd
like to use,
but they've decided to paint you in this
way,
like as as a target because they need to
target to sort of reinforce this idea
that transgender people are being
victimized and women are being
victimized.
Yeah.
Well,
even deeper that the right narrative is
the way that we should view the world is
victim versus oppressor because that's
the basic postmodern new Marxists
template.
It's the right way to view the world is
that it's a power.
It's a power ground.
It's a battle ground of power,
interests competing constantly.
The ones that win are oppressors.
The ones that lose are press.
That's the way you look at the world and
I think that that's wrong.
That's a bad way of looking at the world
psychologically,
sociologically,
politically,
economically,
ideologically,
you name it.
It ends nothing but catastrophe.
I mean,
first of all because it puts your group
identity as something that's paramount
and I mean that's just not.
While that for that isn't what we do in
the West.
Let's say we put your individual
identity paramount and then.
Well that's just,
that's just for starters fundamentally.
And then I guess the other reason that
people are on my case to some degree is
because I have made a strong case,
which I think is fully documented by the
scientific literature that there are
intrinsic differences say between men
and women.
And I think the evidence in that.
This is the thing that staggered me,
is that no serious scientists have that
for like four decades.
It's that argument was done by the time
I went to graduate school.
Everyone knew that human beings,
we're not a blank slate.
That biological forces,
no parameterize the way that we thought
and felt and acted in and and valued.
Everyone knew that the fact that this
has become somehow debatable again is
just,
especially because it's being done by
legislative Fiat,
they're forcing it to me as a scientist
is just,
it's just well.
And in the states too,
with title,
with title nine for example,
because title nine is sort of predicated
on that viewpoint.
What is title nine?
Title nine was originally just a piece
of legislation that mandated that female
sports teams were funded to the same
degree that male sports teams were
funded in the American universities,
but it's been expanded out so that if
there's any differences in any areas
whatsoever between the genders than the
universities are being taken to court
and like $200 meeting last I looked
about 200 of them more up and they can
have their funding revoked if they
violate the title nine provisions,
so it's become like a vicious weapon for
social justice,
Warrior,
equality of outcome types and so it's
not just about sports.
No,
it's got way,
way beyond that.
Yeah,
it's,
it's become an equality of outcome
issue.
Fundamentally.
There was an article that I sent you.
One of them was from,
I think I got it off of Digg.com,
but it was Jordan Peterson is having his
moment and we should ignore them.
I send this to and there was one part of
it.
Probably
the last part of that might be true,
but one of the things in the article was
citing this study that showed very
little different.
Oh God.
It's pathetic study.
Yeah.
I send it to you because I was like
this.
This is not right.
Well,
the thing is like most things,
it's complicated.
Yes.
You know,
so our men and women more similar or
more different.
Well,
it depends on how you define the terms
first,
but they're more similar.
Well,
why?
they're the same species.
So we could start with that like,
but the question is what are the
differences and how do they manifest
themselves and are those manifestations
important?
So here's an example.
If you took a random woman out of the
population and a random matt and you had
to bet on who was more temperamentally
aggressive.
If you bet on the man you'd be right 60
percent of the time,
but you'd be wrong 40 percent of the
time.
And that's not a walloping difference,
right?
60 slash 40.
It's not 90 10.
Like.
So there's quite,
there's a lot of overlap between men and
women in terms of their levels of
aggression and you think,
well,
they're more of the same.
Yeah.
Except so then let's say no,
no,
let's play a slightly different game.
Let's pick the one in 100 most
aggressive person from the random
population while they're all men.
And that's why all the people in prison
are men.
So even though on average men and women,
yeah,
it's 90,
90,
90 to 95 percent,
right?
So,
and often if the women are in prison,
it's because they got tangled up with a
really bad guy,
you know?
So.
So one of the problems is,
is that differences at the extreme are
where the differences really start to
manifest themselves.
And so you can have a small difference
at the level of the average.
But out at the extremes it starts to
make a massive difference.
So let's say to be a google engineer,
which is hard,
right?
Because not only you have to be an
engineer,
but you have to be a very good engineer,
say,
well,
you have to be interested in things
rather than people.
That's,
that's a huge difference in interests.
Like men are more interested in things
generally speaking and women are more
interested in people generally speaking
now.
There's still a lot of overlap between
them,
but that's one of the biggest
differences between men and women.
It's been demonstrated cross culturally.
It's also very big difference in the
Scandinavian countries.
Well,
on average,
the difference isn't that great even
though it's a relatively large
difference.
But at the extremes,
it's the same thing.
Almost all the people that are hyper,
um,
what would you call hyperfocused on
things?
They're almost all men and all the
people who are hyperfocused on people
are almost all women.
And so how does that play out in the
world?
Well,
in the Scandinavian countries,
it plays out this way,
but 85 percent of nurses in Scandinavia
are female and about 85 to 90 percent of
engineers are male.
It doesn't mean women can't be
engineers.
It doesn't mean men can't be nurses.
It also doesn't have anything to do with
intelligence,
but it does have to do with interest and
the differences in interest are big now
at the extremes in particular.
So when you read a review like that,
the one that was pointed out,
the first question is,
well,
what do you mean by big and little?
There's more overlap.
There's more overlap between men and
women than there is difference on
virtually every parameter.
Okay,
fine.
Are the remaining differences
significant in how they play out in the
world or the answer to that is
overwhelmingly significant because you,
you,
you select for extremes.
So here's another example.
Ashkenazi Jews have an average Iq of
115.
So in the typical population overall has
an average Iq of 100.
15 points is about the difference
between the typical college student and
the typical high school student.
Okay?
So it's not a massive difference,
but if you go to the extreme say,
well let's go look at people who only
have an Iq of 145,
which is kind of where you hit the
beginnings of genius level.
So like the Jews are overwhelmingly
overrepresented,
so relatively small differences in the
average can produce walloping
differences at the extremes and people
don't understand that it's not
surprising because it actually requires
a fairly sophisticated grasp of
statistics,
but when we're talking about things like
differential outcome in the workplace,
um,
then you have to take a sophisticated
statistical approach to it or you don't
know what the hell you're talking about.
And unfortunately many of the people who
are talking about things like gender
differences,
they have no idea what they're talking
about.
They don't know the literature,
they don't know there is a literature,
they don't understand biology,
like the social constructionist types,
the women's studies types,
the Neo Marxists,
they don't give a damn about biology.
It's like they inhabit some disembodied
universe.
So the review was poorly written at best
and did not,
was showed it a very poor grasp of the
relationship between group differences
and economic and practical outcomes.
It's not just that it's deceptive and
there's,
there's a need in some way on that side,
this side of the debate,
the Anti Jordan Peterson side to label
men and women as being virtually
identical when there's so much evidence
that that's not the case.
And what your saying?
Well you've,
you've never said one is superior,
one is inferior.
What you are is a guy who's pointing out
the reality of the difference between
the various types of human beings and
you've been very open about the extremes
about,
look,
I'm,
I'm well aware of the extremes.
I deal with MMA fighters.
I know a lot of female mma fighters are
as aggressive and as tough as any man
you're ever going to meet in your life.
And I know a lot of men from comedy that
are meek little guys who they're not
nearly as aggressive as some of these
female fighters.
Like there's.
I think one of the beautiful things
about freedom is that people get an
opportunity to express themselves in a
way that genuinely them and whether that
is like our friend Alex honnold,
who's a free climber who was like
climbing up these fantastic mountains
with no ropes or whether it's a female
mma fighter like Raquel Pennington,
it was just a tank and beating the shit
out of people and that's what she loves
to do.
All of these extremes are available to
people because of freedom.
This is not a suppressive thing.
No one's stopping people from choosing
these paths.
I don't know if you saw the most recent
slipup by the CEO of Youtube.
Um,
I retweeted it today.
they were talking about why there's not
as many women in tech.
And she basically said they,
both her and the CEO of Google said
exactly what James Damore was saying in
his memo.
They completely fucked up.
They tried to find this.
Look at this.
This is Goddamn hilarious.
And James Demore had this on his page.
They respond to women.
A lack of tech goes.
Could you know,
go to go to James Damore tweet.
Just go to the,
the what I retweeted and what he said.
So there was a study published a while
ago or
no?
Jamie,
scroll back up.
It was right there.
It's right there.
Just just make his tweet larger.
There you go.
Let's it.
He's saying,
did I read this right?
I don't know how to say her name is.
Susan would have.
Sorry,
I don't know how to say her name.
W A W O
J I c I c k.
I said that women find Geeky male
industries as opposed to social
industry's not very interesting.
And Sundar cites research on gender
differences.
That's exactly the difference in
interest that I just pointed out.
That's exactly right.
This is what James Damore wrote in his
memo that got him fired.
And this in my mind,
if I was the lawyer for James Demore and
be like,
oh,
well look what we have here.
This is,
this is checkmate.
You dummies just at the divorce story is
really interesting,
you know,
because I think it's such a classic
story of,
of an engineer getting tangled up in
politics.
So demora went to this diversity seminar
and he wasn't very happy about it
because he knew the literature and so at
the end of the seminar they asked for
feedback,
well James Morris,
an engineer,
so when you tell an engineer that you
want feedback,
the engineer thinks,
oh,
you want feedback and the and you want
like facts and stuff,
right?
Because that's what feedback would be
like.
So demora went and wrote this like
thoreau memo and gave it to them.
He said,
well,
you know,
this is what I think,
here's some feedback.
And then it traveled around the.
He got no real response from the
diversity of people and then he posted
it on one of these internal boards at
Google where people can discuss things,
which people at Google do all the time.
So it was perfectly reasonable for him
to post it because he didn't get a
response from the diversity people.
He thought,
well,
let's see what other people think.
And then it was there for a long time
until it was leaked out into the outside
world.
It wasn't like Demora was trying to
expose Google for for what it is.
He was just doing what an engineer type
would do when someone asked him to
provide feedback because he's not
thinking politically.
He's not thinking,
oh,
they just want to hear what they already
said.
He thought they actually wanted some
facts anyways.
I think they picked on the wrong guy
because it turns out to be pretty damn
tough.
But he's very smart and a very kind guy.
When you sit down and talk to him,
he's not a sexist.
He's a.
he's a guy that's talking about facts.
In fact,
he wrote more than a page and a half,
I believe on strategies for getting more
women interested in tech.
He's not a sexist.
This is just a guy that was talking
about the differences in the choices
that people make that it's based on just
the variations that you were just
discussing.
Well there,
there's a good study done awhile ago and
unfortunately to remember the author,
but they were looking at junior high
math prodigies and they're pretty
equally distributed between boys and
girls,
but by the time university came along,
they math prodigy boys,
they tend to go into the stem fields but
the girls wouldn't and it doesn't
because they lacked ability because they
had stellar ability.
It's because they weren't interested and
it turns out like the interesting turns
out to be a big one.
So with personality alone,
if you measure men and women's
personalities and then you add up all
the differences in personalities,
you could tell with about 75 to 80
percent certainty by looking at a full
personality readout whether persons male
or female.
So you'd be wrong 25 percent of the
time,
something like that.
But if you add interest to that,
you can get it up to about 90 percent.
And so you know,
you say,
well,
are these differences large?
Well,
individually they're not that big.
They make more difference at the
extremes,
but if you add them up then you can
almost completely differentiate men from
women.
So by that token there,
they're very large and the interesting
actually turns out to matter a lot like
it's probably the most important
individual difference that has been
discovered between men and women at the
psychological level and has real decent
explanatory power because you might say,
well men have a slight edge and spatial
intelligence and that's why they're
overrepresented in stem fields and women
have a slight edge and verbal
intelligence.
This is debatable,
but literature kind of indicates that
and that's why they're overwhelmingly
the majority of fiction readers for
example,
is that the reason that there's
differential representation in the stem
fields,
it's like,
no,
it doesn't seem to be.
It doesn't look like it's an
intellectual issue,
which is also what the more pointed out.
By the way,
he never said once that this was a
cognitive issue,
but it's a matter of choice.
Matter of interest and women tend to be
more more people oriented.
Now the thing is,
this has also been discovered in
chimpanzees and other primates.
Like if you offer baby or child
chimpanzees,
juvenile chimpanzees,
the toys choice between thing,
like toys,
like cars or people like toys,
like dolls,
the males will go for the thing like
toys and the females would go for the
people like toys.
So you see that in primates and you
think,
well he's not surprising.
It's like,
well no it's not.
It's not that surprising really mean
women have to take care of infants,
tiny infants and you have to be really
people oriented to do that because a
tiny infant isn't unbelievably demanding
social relationship and it's a primary
relationship for about two years,
you know?
And so women are tilted towards the kind
of temperament that makes that possible.
It's like,
well,
it's not such a shock really.
That's such a surprise.
So no,
it's not a surprise in what.
What's confusing to me is the narrative
that anybody that points out these
differences is somehow a sexist or
discriminatory or.
Yeah.
Well,
whatever epithet can.
I think the other reason that the left
the radical lefties have been going
after me constantly as well.
There's one reason is if you stand up
against the radical radical left,
you're in a group that also has Nazis in
it because the Nazis also stand up
against the radical left,
so it's perfectly reasonable from a
strategic perspective for the radical
leftists who say,
well,
you're against us.
How do we know where you're not a Nazi?
It's like,
well,
statistically,
statistically I'm probably not,
you know,
so there's that.
But,
but you could say at least the question
is open,
but,
but then the next part of it comes is
that it's motivated epithet slinging,
because if I'm reasonable and I'm
standing up against the radical left and
they admit that I'm reasonable,
then there has to be an admission that
reasonable people could stand up against
the radical left,
which kind of implies that the radical
left isn't that reasonable.
And so while they're not going to go
there,
of course they're not out reasonable or
unreasonable beyond belief.
As we saw in a situation with Lindsay
Shepherd in Canada.
So at Wilfrid laurier university.
Talk about that real quick because that
was a fascinating thing to.
And that also had to do with you,
so she was discussing you in class and
he'd fill up on everybody.
She's in communications in the
communications department at Wilfrid
Laurier,
and they were talking about the role of
language and communication,
which kind of what you would do in a
communication class.
And she decided to show a five minute
clip from a program I had done for TV
Ontario,
which is a public television station,
mainstream,
left leaning Liberal television station
news program and a good one,
a good one.
And I had been on there with a number of
other people,
including a professor Nicolas,
Matt from the University of Toronto who
claimed essentially that there were no
biological differences between men and
women.
And that had been the scientific
consensus for the last four decades.
So anyways,
she showed a clip from this and well she
got hauled in front of two professors,
ended administrator,
Adrian Joel,
who was basically hired for that purpose
and raked over the coals for daring to
show this video.
And she had the wherewithal to tape it.
And then she made the tape public.
And in that tape they compared me,
it was,
it was really blackley comical,
you know,
they compared me to Hitler and,
but then said,
well,
it's Hitler or Milo Yiannopoulos.
I thought you guys just so damn
clueless.
He can't even get your insults right.
It's like he can't say that's like
playing a video of Hitler or Milo
Yiannopoulos.
It's like,
first of all,
Hitler and Milo Yiannopoulos,
they're actually not in the same
category,
right?
Except that they're both human.
That's about the narrowness of the
category.
And then Milo's a,
like a comic provocateur and you can
hate him or love him or,
or be indifferent,
but to put them in the same category as
Hitler just shows how muddle headed you
are.
And then to assimilate me to that
category.
So carelessly like you don't mess about
with epithets like that.
Know Hitler was one of the Great Super
Villains of the 20th century.
Right?
I mean,
he was,
he's up there with Stalin and Mao in
the,
in the,
in the panoply of Satanic Lee possessed
leaders.
You don't just toss that around,
especially not when you're torturing
your teaching assistant for daring to
show a video about language in a
communication class,
and so that was a massive scandal in
Canada was the biggest skill.
I think it was the biggest scandal that
ever hit a university in Canada and it
got a lot of international attention and
rightly so,
and she also turns out to be a tough
cookie.
I mean,
the last I heard she was,
she'd started a club at Wilford laurier
and I think it was last night or the
night before,
maybe it's coming up.
They're going to show the whole video
from Television Ontario at a club
meeting and invite people to come and
discuss it.
It's like they.
They picked on the wrong girl there too,
so there's certainly didn't choose.
Obviously very smart.
You can hear that in her discussion with
them and how flabbergasted she was by
their take on things,
but this was essentially proof to a lot
of people that were on the outside of
how preposterous some of the dialogue
was inside these universities and they
couldn't have done me a bigger favor
than having that scandal because when I
made the videos about bill see 16,
15 months ago,
I said,
look,
here's what's going to happen because
this legislation is written in an
appalling manner and the surrounding
policies are pathological.
Said,
here's what's going to happen,
and so I laid it out and then people
came out and said,
no,
you're being paranoid.
It's like,
that's possible.
No,
the bill,
the legislation isn't going to have that
effect.
No,
you're not a legal expert.
What the hell do you know?
Et Cetera,
et cetera.
You're crazy.
You're a bigot.
You're a transformed.
You know,
they,
they threw everything but the kitchen
sink at me and like,
fair enough,
you know,
because there's always the possibility
that I was wrong.
But the problem was is I read the
policies and I understood them and I
knew where they were leading,
but I never imagined that one of the
consequences of bill [inaudible] and its
sister legislation was that a teaching
assistant at a Canadian university would
be pilloried and accused of breaking the
law and then accused of all sorts of
reprehensible political beliefs by two
professors and an administrator hired
for that purpose.
I'm merely because she showed a video
about two people talking about the law.
It's like that,
that paranoid as I am,
let's say that that exceeded the grasp
or the reach of my imagination.
And then of course it was made public
and people just couldn't believe it.
And then you think,
okay,
well what's the defense?
Well,
they misinterpreted bill [inaudible].
So like,
no,
I don't think so.
Um,
they aren't representative of the
university professor at administration.
Well,
all of pim lot and rambo kindness
colleagues rose to their defense,
the whole department,
the university,
when they apologized,
did it in a very mealy mouth way.
Like there's no evidence that it was an
anomalous occurrence.
So what had happened is they
overextended the reach of bill,
see 16 in exactly the way that I said
would happen.
It was inevitable and it wasn't an
anomaly.
It was actually.
That's actually the way that the
universities are and it is the way that
they are.
It wasn't a one off,
it was exactly diagnostic and it's
appalling.
It's appalling.
The universities have so much to be
ashamed of their their there.
While there was an article in the Boston
Globe this week saying the same thing,
that all of this crazy postmodern
identity politics,
equality of outcome nonsense is not only
disrupted the university in a way that
might be irreparable as far as I can
tell,
but it's rapidly spreading outside into
the normal say business world,
which was exactly what you see.
For example,
at Google.
Well the tech industry in particular
seems to be more left leaning than
pretty much any industry there is and I
guess it's because there's so many
intelligent people.
There are so many people that has spent
a tremendous amount of time in
universities and they get indoctrinated
into this mindset and you're.
You're seeing that in this,
the CEO of youtubes response to the
James Damore memo completely
misrepresented it to the other talking
about harmful gender stereotypes.
That's not what he talked about at all.
What what's fascinating to me about all
of this is it,
it just reeks of tribalism that these
people on the left have decided.
I mean,
and I'm mostly on the left,
which is really crazy.
I mean when it comes to most policies
and most thoughts of equality and and
the idea of just letting people be who
they are.
I mean that's what the left used to
stand for,
do use to stand for being open minded,
and he used to stand for being a
reasonable person.
It now it seems to be all about this
very toxic tribal ideology and this is
one of the reasons why so many of these
attacks and you are so baffling to me as
because there's a willful ignorance or a
deceptive narrative there.
There's a deceptive description of who
you are and what you're saying and what
you represent,
and it's this conveniently categorize,
not even convenient,
willfully ignore,
willfully deceptively categorized into
these categories,
categories of homophobia,
transphobia,
sexism.
These are reprehensible categories that
if they can just shove something that
you're saying,
figuring out a way to push you into this
little narrow confined than how everyone
has to disagree with you.
Everyone has to insult you in.
Everyone has to take that girl into
their office and chastise you for even.
You're not even speaking up for you.
Right?
She said she wasn't.
Yes.
That's what was more fascinating about
it than anything.
Then they give her hell for that.
Like all.
You can't present something like that
neutrally.
That's like presenting something Hitler
said neutrally or maybe Milo
Yiannopoulos.
It's.
It's so strange,
but what they don't understand,
and this is what's really crazy,
is that the world is watching and that
most people,
maybe it's a 60 slash 40 like we were
talking about before when it comes to
aggressive women versus aggressive men.
I don't know what the number.
I think it's almost 50 to one,
actually my.
I've been watching the comments on
youtube and so forth,
trying to track this is like I think
that like I think that what the radical
leftists are doing is overwhelmingly
unrepresentative of the general
population overwhelmingly,
but they're.
They're a very well organized and and
verbal and prepared minority and they've
occupied powerful positions in many,
many institutions.
Hr and one of the things I really can't
figure out right now and for anybody
who's running a company that's
listening,
they should think this through,
like to let these postmodern Neo
Marxists into your company through the
guise of human resources is an absolute
catastrophe.
You're going to pay for that.
This ideology that drives postmodern,
neo Marxism,
this identity politics,
what the identity politics movement and
its insistence on equality of outcome is
a powerfully anticapitalistic.
It's powerfully anti-western.
Why you would let that into your company
is so that you can look good.
Socially,
let's say is beyond me.
It's a big mistake.
I agree with you,
but I don't think people are aware of
it.
I think part of the problem is this
battleground is largely ignored by the
general population.
I don't think most people are aware of
what's going on.
You are,
because you're obviously you're deeply
embedded in the university system in
Canada and you're.
You're obviously now branching out into
youtube and podcasts and all these
different ways to get this information
out,
but the average person that is a ceo of
a company or they're.
They're concerned with their own
company,
they're concerned with their own
individual needs,
their concern with organizing things and
keeping their bottom line
well.
They're also concerned with looking fair
and making sure that they're not
prejudice and all of that,
which is laudable and.
But I just don't think they see the wave
coming now.
They don't.
They don't see it coming.
They don't understand it and they're in
conscious about it,
but they're going to pay for it.
Well,
Google is a good example because now
google is in court on the feminist end
for like being prejudiced against
females and also on the conservative end
for being prejudice against
conservatives.
It's like,
well,
so both camps or after the men.
I think,
well,
why is that?
It's like,
well,
that's what happens when you play
identity politics.
This tribalism or this is really what I
can't stand about,
identity politics and I've been warning
about the consequences of on the right
wing too because what I see happening is
that as the left,
like let's say the left gets to define
the linguistic territory,
which was what I was objecting to and
bill [inaudible] when it came out,
I said,
look,
I'm not going to use these neologisms z
and etc.
Because as far as I'm concerned,
they have nothing.
Don't know what you're talking aBout.
Different made up gender pronouns to
describe people in the non male or
female.
That's right.
So there's like 70 different categories
of non binary gender or something like
that generated now and there's lists of
pronouns that hypothetically the people
who are in those categories can choose
to be addressed by and now that has the
force of law and so and I don't care if
they choose to be addressed by those
pronouns,
whatever.
That's,
that's,
that's up to them and whoever else they
can convInce or ask or in treat or
negotiate with,
fine.
As soon as it's law,
that's a whole different.
Okay,
so now I have to use a certain
terminology.
So then I look at the derivation of the
I say,
oh,
that's terminology generated by the
postmodern neo marxists.
Oh,
well I think those people are
reprehensible,
murderous.
So guess what?
I'm not going to say their words period,
because I know what they're like.
I know where that leads.
Okay,
so
bumps on.
Most people think that that's a gigantic
step to go from saying you don't want to
say z or z or any of these made up
gender pronouns too.
These are murderous people.
The ideology is murderous.
The edlp being marxism.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Well jesus,
how much proof do you need?
But most people don't understand
marxism.
Like when you,
when you're saying this,
like when you were so adamant about it,
I had to start reading about it myself
and I had started doing a lot of
research about it myself and I think
most people here marxism and they think
socialism,
they think pooling all your money
together,
you know,
making,
making things more.
Even in Venezuela,
everybody has an equal chance to starve
to death.
So you know how they,
you know,
how the venezuelan government star solve
the problem of kids starving to death in
hospitals.
How they maDe it illegal for the doctors
to report starvation as the cause of
death.
Right.
Wow.
That's Venezuela in a nutshell.
Yeah.
Everyone's equal there.
They all have the same number of bones
to know on it.
That's a horrible thing,
but it's a horrible thing.
Undeniably.
But there's no like the connection
between gender pronouns and murder this.
It's a big leap.
Yeah,
that's,
that's for sure.
That's for sure.
Well,
that's why you have to look at the
underlying etiology,
you know,
when you think,
well,
what's,
what level at what is the level at which
these things should be addressed?
While is it economic,
is it political,
personal things of these,
this ideology and you understand where
the roadmap leads.
You understand the x at the end of the
road.
Yeah,
right.
Absolutely.
Well,
and I think that's why I recommended to
people continually to read soldier and
hudson's gulag archipelago.
So actually there's a set of books that
let lay this out perfectly.
You reaD dostoyevsky's wrote a book
called the or the devils and it's a,
it's a description of the initial
breakdown of the of orthodox christian
society and in Russia in the late 18
hundreds and the rise of radical
socialist ideas.
So it's sorta like the pro drama to the
russian revolution to brilliant,
brilliant book,
and it concentrates on the personalities
that are involved.
And then if you read after that social
hudson's gulag archipelago where he
details what he does in that book is
quite remarkable.
So he says,
look,
there were tens of millions of people
killed from 19,
19 to 1959 in the soviet union and as a
consequence of internal repression,
and it's so dreadful that words can't do
it justice.
I mean,
it's absolutely dreadful what happened
in the soviet union.
I mean,
just for starters,
6 million ukrainians died in the 19
thirties because of enforced,
in fact,
in,
in the 19 thirties.
Here's,
here's how,
here's how terrible it was.
So all the food that the collective
farmers,
newly collectivized farmers had
produced,
which wasn't very much by the way,
was taken from them and brought to the
cities.
So all the farmers starve to death.
Now here's,
here's how draconian it got.
So let's say you are the mother of some
children and all your grain had been
shipped off to the cities and you
thought,
well,
I'm not going to have my children starve
to death.
I'm going to go out in the field and I'm
going to have on my hands and knees and
I'm going to pick up the grains that are
leftover that the harvesters didn't
count.
Get.
And I'm going to feed those to my kids.
That was punishable by death.
You were supposed To handy in those
extra bits of grain so that they could
be shipped to the city as well.
So that was just the beginning of the
fund and the soviet union.
And what solzhenitsyn did was say,
look,
this wasn't a consequence of the marxist
system gone wrong.
This was a consequence of the marxist
system.
It waS inevitable consequence of the
axioms of the marxist system.
And then he lays that out and it's all.
I think he got it right.
What is the nobel prize?
But what is the connection?
How much tyranny you have to impose in
order to produce something like equality
of outcome?
Either the,
the thomas sowell is talked about this a
little bit too.
He said what the people who are
agitating for equality of outcome don't
understand is that you have to seed so
much power to the authorities,
to the government in order to ensure
equality of outcome,
that a tyranny is inevitable.
And that's right.
And the other problem with equality of
outcome,
this is also a big technical problem is
like,
well what measure of outcome?
You know,
there's lots of outcomes,
like how happy are you?
How much pain are you in?
How healthy are you?
How much money do you have?
How much opportunity for movement
forward do you have?
What's the width of your social
connections?
Like what's the quality of your
friendships?
Do you have exposure to art and
literature?
Like you know,
you can multiply the number of
dimensions of evaluation between people
innumerably,
right?
Because there's,
there's all sorts of ways to classify
people.
You're going to get equality of outcome
on every one of those measures.
It's like everyone going to have to be
equally happy in their relationship and
if not,
why not?
What?
Why?
Why stop with economic livestock with
pay,
there's no place to stop.
So and that's.
And that's a huge technical problem
because there is no place to stop.
There will be no stopping.
It's like nobody can have anything else,
nobody can have anything that everyone
else doesn't have.
At the same time,
that's the ultimate outcome of equality
of outcome.
While you think about what that would
mean,
it's terrible.
Well,
instantly you think,
oh,
well there's nothing but a tyrannical
system could impose that.
Have you ever debated and marks
supporter?
Have you ever debated someone who is pro
equality of outcome?
No,
they don't debate me.
Well,
the only.
The closest thing I think was two.
That was the debate I did at the
university of toronto about the bill,
see 16 issues,
but they didn't actually have a debate.
They had a forum which is the postmodern
equivalent of a debate.
It's supposed to be friendlier I
suppose,
but no,
I haven't because people don't do it.
They don't ask me to do it,
but what is it about that idea or that
ideology about marxism that's so
attractive to young students and two
university professors?
A good question.
I think it goes back to the issue of
inequality and this is something that
has to be dead seriously addressed.
He might say,
well,
why is the left wing necessary?
Let let's,
let's put it that way.
So,
and then a subset of that would be,
well,
why is the left wing attractive?
Well,
the left wing is necessary because
inequality does spiral out of control
and so there has to be a political voice
for the dispossessed and you don't want
people to stack up at zero,
you know,
where they can't play the game at all.
It's a bad idea.
Not only do you not,
if people stack up at zero,
they're too poor to get ahead at all.
Let's say there are too poor to open a
bank account.
There are too poor to buy enough food,
like they're stuck at zero and they
can't get out of it.
It's a really bad scene because first of
all,
that's a lot of suffering and that's not
so good.
Second of all,
well at least in principle,
a lot of those people might be what
might have something to offer the world
or their children might and you want to
open up avenues of opportunity to them
so that they can succeed,
but so that everyone else can benefit
from their success.
So,
and then the next thing is,
well,
if the inequality gets out of hand too
much,
then the whole society starts to
destabilize because if you get enough
people stacked up at zero,
especially young men,
you get enough young men stacked up at
zero,
they think,
oh to hell with it,
we'll just flip the whole board over and
it'll settle in a new configuration and
maybe we won't be stuck at zero in the
new configuration.
so it foments revolutionary thinking.
So there's lots of reasons to be
concerned about inequality and so you
need a voice on the left to say,
look,
we got to parameterize the tendency
towards inequality so that it doesn't
destabilize the entire society so that
it's.
Everybody has an opportunity to advance.
Like,
yes,
right.
You need that.
Okay.
So that's the technical reason for the
necessity of the left.
And then I think it's attractive
because.
well,
because young people can be resentful
partly because they're at the bottom of
the heap,
so to speak.
They're not [inaudible].
They're young,
like,
look,
you want to be,
you want to be poor in 18,
you want to be rich and 80,
which you're going to choose.
Most people is going to take poor at 18.
Oh yeah.
Especially if you've been richard 80 and
you understand you can get back there.
Yeah.
Well that's the thing you know,
is that most of the people who are have
a million dollars or more in the United
States,
our old.
well why is that?
Well really do we need an explanation
for that?
It's like you've had a lot more time to
make money.
How would that be?
That's the explanatIon.
So that's one of the big drivers of
inequality is just simply age,
but it's not obvious that the old rich
people have an advantage over the young
starting out people so,
so anyways,
but any.
Anyhow,
maybe you're resentful and irritated
because you're young and you're still at
the bottom of the heap and you know
you've got other problems too.
It's more difficult for people of your
race or ethnicity or gender.
At least you think it is.
And so you say,
well,
I want to make things fair,
and then that's also driven by some real
compassion because nobody really likes
that.
The consequences of radical inequality,
like nobody likes the fact that homeless
people exist and have to go to the
emergency ward,
you know,
to get treated and they don't have
medical coverage and they have to live
in tents on the street.
And so if you have some compassion,
then you think,
well,
we got to do more for the poor and
dispossessed.
It's like,
okay,
that's,
that's an understandable sentiment.
But the problem is,
is that the people.
is that it's that,
that,
that desire to help is contaminated by
resentment and ideological certainty.
And then also by something that george
orwell pointed out so nicely in his
book,
road to wigan pier.
It's like the typical middle class
socialist.
This was his diagnosis and he was a
socialist by the way.
His diagnosis was the typical
middleclass.
Intellectual socialist doesn't like the
poor.
In fact,
they don't have anything to do with the
poor,
their contemptuous of the poor,
but they hate the rich.
And I think it's even more devious than
that because I think who they hate are
the successful,
some of the successful or rich,
but really who they hate is the
successful.
It's cain and abel.
It's the retelling of cain and abel,
and so there's some positive motivations
for being engaged on the left and
there's a lot of negative motivations as
well,
and the people who are really driven by
the radical left ideology that real
radicals,
they're almost all driven by by
resentment and hatred as far as I'm
concerned now the law.
LeT's look at both extremes.
So back to the idea of the of the
ideological and verbal territory.
I said with bill [inaudible] that I
wouldn't speak the language of the
radical leftist because I don't think
that that language should define the
game,
but let's say it does.
So here's the game.
the world is a battleground of groups
and the are battling for power.
That's it.
That's the game.
And some of them win and they oppress
those who don't win.
So that's how we're going to view the
world.
Okay?
Now the left is say,
okay,
well here's the oppressed people,
the oppressors,
the patriarchy type patriarchal type
space should be ashamed of themselves
and give up some power.
The right wingers,
the radical right wingers look at that
and they say,
oh,
I see,
so the game is ethnic identity.
Is identity politics,
okay?
Were white males.
We're not going to lose.
That's the right wing version of
identity politics.
It's like,
screw you.
If we're going to divide into groups,
if we're going to divide into tribes and
I'm in my tribe,
I'm not going to get all guilty and
lose,
I'm going to get all cruel and win,
and that's like.
Then you think,
well,
there's people in the middle.
They're kind of looking back and forth
which side of the identity politics
spectrum I am I get a fallen.
do I want to go with,
do I want to go?
Do I want to be driven primarily by
compassion and I'm,
am I going to accept guilt for my
historical privilege?
So that's one possibility.
And then I'm the oppressor.
I'm the member of the oppressor group,
or am I going to say no to hell with
that?
I'm just going to play to win.
Well then I'm going to go to the right.
It's like,
well,
my sense is how about we don't play
either of those games and the reason we
shouldn't play the miss?
Well,
the soviet played the left lean game and
like killed.
Who knows how many tens of millions of
people.
You can't even count it accurately.
The estimates range from 20 to 100
million.
Those are pretty big error bars and that
numologists maybe a $100 million.
Certainly $60 million,
so okay.
That didn't work out so well,
and then there's the nazis.
They played ethnic identity politics and
racial superiority.
It's like,
why do we want to play that game?
See what I've been trying to do,
really what I've been trying to do for
the last 30 years is say,
look,
there's heavy temptations to play those
sorts of games,
but that's not the only game in town.
It's a much better game to play
individual.
It's like get your act together,
stand up in the world,
make something of yourself,
stay away from the ideological
oversimplifications,
set your house in order.
That's rule six in the,
in the,
in this book,
so I have a book rule in there,
says set your house in perfect order
before he criticized the world and it's
a very dark chapter about the
motivations of the columbine high school
killers and this other guy named carl
pans ram,
who was a serial rapist and arsonist and
murderer,
and he wrote an autobiography and the
columbine kids also wrote about why they
did what they did.
They're resentful to the core,
bitter,
resentful,
terrible and well,
I'm suggesting that people stay away
from that resentment.
Resentfulness And bitterness,
even though life is hard and,
and there's malevolence in the world.
It's like,
yeah,
you can,
you can tell a story where everyone's a
victim because we all die.
We all get sick,
you know,
and,
and things happened to us that are
bitter and terrible betrayal.
Deceit,
lies like people heard us on purpose,
you know,
so it's not just the tragedy of life,
it's malevolence as well.
It's everyone's a victim.
You can tell that story.
The problem is if you tell that story
and you start to act it out,
you make all of that worse.
That's the problem and it's so.
This is why partly I got attracted to
christian imagery,
at least in part because there's an idea
in christianity that you should pick up
your goddamn cross and like walk up the
hill and that's dramatically.
That's correct.
That's the right answer.
He's like,
you've got a heavy load of suffering to
bear and a fair bit of it's going to be
unjust.
SO what are you going to do about it
except it voluntarily and try to
transform as a consequence.
That's the right answer.
It's the right answer because the rest
of it is tribalism and were too
technologically powerful to get all
tribal again.
What's exciting to me is that
I think this is the first time in my
life that I've ever seen so much
communication on these subjects and I
think so much recognition about the
consequences of tribal toxic tribalism,
this tribal thinking that everyone seems
to be engaged in on the right and on the
left.
I mean in America,
you need to go no further than going
back and forth from cnn to fox news to
say something's wrong here.
These are,
these are supposed to be news outlets.
You have to completely dIfferent
narratives and that has nothing to do
with what we're talking about with
gender politics and radical left
socialism and marxism.
W what what you're seeing in
universities though is a radical
departure from what I always considered
universities.
Great for what I always considered
universities great for is separating
from your parents challenging belief
systems and being engaged in the the
works of brilliant people who you can
compare all of their findings and their
discoveries and sit down and debate them
in class and when I was a kid,
when I was in high school,
went to a very good high school.
Newton South high school in newton,
Massachusetts,
and uh,
one of the thIngs that they did is they
put on a debate between a guy from the
moral majority,
which was this a right wing,
a christian group that I don't even know
if they're around anymore,
but there,
this was 19,
I was 14,
so 81 and a barney frank who was that
congressman's now one of the first
openly gay guys in congress.
And,
and,
uh,
you got to watch these two people in
this auditorium debate there their
points in this mara majority guy had
this,
you know,
right wing ronald reagan's sort of point
of view and barney frank was kinda crazy
and he's got busted in some male
prostitutes scandal.
And,
but the gay community,
that's not that big of a deal.
And uh,
just barney frank took them apart.
It was brilliant to watch.
But it was a real debate.
It was fascinating and he got to see a,
a mediocre mine versus a great mind.
And you got to see this little thing.
And I was like,
wow,
this is one of the things that's always
attracted me about the,
the idea that two people with different
viewpoints can get together in front of
a neutral audience and these people can
sort of decipher which,
which way these people were thinking and
why they're thing.
Yeah.
Well I'm in bad.
Is that is rife with conflict,
that as that is the alternative is to
separate,
as you pointed out into two camps that
don't talk.
Yes.
And the thing is that the consequence of
not talking is that you fight that
that's the end game because the only way
you can stop from fighting with other
people is by negotiating with them.
And you know,
one of the things that's also
interesting,
and this is partly why silicon valley
leans to the left,
is that a fair bit of your political
preference is determined by your
biological temperament.
It's a strongly influenced.
So if you're a creative type who's kind
of disorderly,
then you're likely to be on the liberal
left end of the distribution.
And if you're a non creative type who's
orderly and,
and especially if you're orderly,
then you tend to be on the right wing
end of things.
And so,
and what?
Well,
why is that?
Why?
Why do those variations exist?
Well,
they exist because some of the time your
best strategy is to do what other people
have done and shut the hell up and just
do it.
Run the algorithm,
right?
The pathways already laid clear.
It works,
stay in the damn rut and move forward.
Okay,
so that's the conservative approach.
And when things are going right,
it's the right approach.
the problem is,
is that sometimes it's not the right
approach because something has shifted
and so something new has to emerge.
And so then there's a bunch of people
who are adapted to the new and those are
the entrepreneurial and creative types.
And of course they dominate silicon
valley because it's a very
entrepreneurial,
it's a very entrepreneurial,
what would you call it?
Geography.
And so they're going to lean to the
left,
but they have to understand.
People have to understand that the left
and the right need each other.
The liberals and the conservatives need
each other liberal start companies,
conservatives run them,
and the problem with the conservatives
is,
well,
they caN only run a company in one
direction because they're conservative.
They don't think outside the box,
but so if the coMpany is working in the
product line is good and everything is
stable,
like hire some conservatives because
they'll maximize efficiency and the move
down that track,
but if the track is no longer going in a
good direction because something's
changed,
the environment's changed.
Well then yOu've got to bring in the
creative people and so we need each
other and the only way that we can
survive the fact that we're different
and the fact that we need each other is
by continually talking.
We have taught constantly.
It's like,
well,
how much of what we're doIng should we
preserve versus how much of what we're
doing should we transform?
And the answer is we don't know because
the environment keeps changing.
So what do we do about that?
We talk.
No,
I was on a cbc,
canadian broadcasting corporation
interview a couple of days ago and they
took me to task.
I tweeted out this,
uh,
this invitation to the keck boys to fill
out this program that I developed called
future authoring.
And it helps people make a plan.
The boys.
Yeah.
Well,
they're,
they're an online group.
They're there,
they run Pakistan.
it's this fictional polity.
It's a,
it's a satire of identity politics.
Essentially.
We're going to,
we're going to be our ethnicity,
highly demonized santa highly demonized
and with good reason for,
with some individual examples of racism
and nazi-ism and there's lots of
misbehavior.
Yeah.
It's like graffiti.
It's like online
graffiti,
something like that.
So,
um,
and,
and the keck boys are the ones who are
often using the pepe memes for.
And you know,
the left regardS peppy as a hate symbol.
Pepe the frog.
Pepe the frog feels good for.
That's kind of reprehensible frog.
And so I tweeted out to them,
I said,
keck boys,
seek your four chan rescue yourself from
the underworld,
use code pepe for future authoring.
So it's free for one week.
So they had to figure out what it meant.
And then I showed this picture of
Michigan j frog,
which is the frog from old warner
brothers,
cartoon dancing frog that wouldn't
perform when anyone's watching it.
So cbc,
hold that out and said,
well look,
aren't you,
aren't you like appealing to the
radical?
RIght?
And I said,
well no,
what I'm doing.
I said,
look,
these people are attracted by the
radical right.
Although they're satirists and juvenile
satirists and graffiti types and you
know,
they're,
they're playing a weird wrinkle being
naughty.
That's exactly what they're doing.
They're provoking and I,
my sense was,
well,
why don't you develop yourself as an
individual and get the hell out of the
ideological trap.
so here's my program,
which helps you write about your future
and that'll help you decide who you are
as an individual because that's the way
out of the ideological trap.
It's like.
And that's the way obviously what's the
way out of tribalism first,
the way out of tribalism is not to never
join a tribe.
You actually have to join a tribe as you
mature,
right?
Because what happens Is first of all,
you're an infant,
then you have your parents to to make a
relationship with,
but then when you move from your
parents,
you have your tribe,
you have your group.
Maybe it's the music you listen to,
it's the gang.
You hang around with whatever.
You have to be socialized into the
tribe.
you have to because otherwise you stay
dependent infant.
Okay,
but now you're socialized into the
tribe.
Was that where it ends?
It's like,
no.
The next thIng to do is differentiate
yourself from the tribe while still
knowing how to behave within the tribe
will.
that's the called the individualism and
that's I think what the west got right?
We figured that out.
It's like yOu're more than your.
You have to be a member of a group
because otherwise you're not socialized
to not good for anyone.
You don't have to be able to play on a
team man.
You have to have team loyalty.
Okay,
but that isn't where you should stop.
You should take the next step and become
a fully developed individual and see.
The problem with being just a group
member is that the group,
it's the problem with conservatism.
The group is a fixed entity,
it has its rules and regulations,
and if you're a Member,
that's all you are,
but the group can go badly wrong,
so the group needs individuals to keep
the group alive and revivified so you
have to become an individual so you can
revivify the group.
That's the call,
that's the call in the west to heroism
essentially to noble way of living is to
develop yourself past your group
identity so that you can reconfigure the
game when that becomes necessary and I
think that there's a very influential
line of developmental psychology
pioneered by john piaget that laid that
out as a developmental.
What would progression first year child.
Then you're a member of a group,
then you're an individual.
It's like get to the individual level.
That's the solution.
It's a solution to tribalism,
but you have to accept responsibility to
do that and this is what your future
authoring program is basically all
about.
Man,
it's.
It's a wonderful program.
It's in along with this book,
rules and guidelines for life.
I think that's one of the things that a
lot of young people are lacking is a
structure to how to go about
establishing who they are in the world.
Yeah.
Well that's,
you know what's really cool and it's
been really quite remarkable I would
say,
is that what I've noticed when I've been
speaking publicly say over the last year
and a half because there's a hole in our
culture where there should be a
discussion about maturity,
truth and responsibility.
No one's talking about that.
Okay,
so now I'll come up and they'll start
talking about that.
I'll say,
look like what should you do with your
life?
Well,
take care of yourself,
but take care of yourself in a way that
also means that simultaneously you're
taking care of your family and that and
taking care of the broader community.
So that's kind of your goal.
So orient yourself towards that personal
success,
but in a way that your success breeds
success.
Because if you're going to establish the
name,
why not established like a really good
day and that's a good one.
It's good for you.
It's good for everyone else.
Yes.
Okay.
That'll give you life.
Some meaning now adopt.
Make a plan,
generate a vision.
That's what the future authoring program
helps people with mega.
Develop a vision of what your life could
be like if if it was worth living
despite all its suffering.
It's like what would you need so that
you would be happy to be alive.
You'd find your life meaningful so you
don't get all bitter and resentful and
cruel and hostile and ideologically
adult and like murderous and genocidal.
It's like none of that.
You think real hard.
How would you have to configure your
life so that despite its suffering and
the malevolence that's part of it,
that you would regard it as worthwhile.
It's not.
It's up to you to develop a vision.
Then put a plan into practice and so
when I talk to people about this and
most of my audiences or young men,
it's probably about 65 slash 35.
More and more women are showing up,
but that's about what it is right now.
The halls are dead silent.
You could hear a pin drop because
nobody's said so clearly for like 50
years that almost all the meaning that
you will need to get you through the
hard times of your life is going to be a
consequence of adopting responsibility,
not have rights and impulsive action.
Impulsive freedom like fine rights.
Yeah,
got it.
Freedom,
no problem.
Even freedom to do impulsive things,
fine,
but that isn't where you're going to
find the meaning that keeps you
sustained through the storms of life
that's going to be take care of
yourself.
You take care of your intimate partner,
you take care of your damn family.
You don't run off.
You take care of your community.
You rescue the wisdom from the past.
You stand up straight and he be
courageous despite the fact that life is
tragic and tainted by malevolence.
It's like that's the.
That's ancient.
That's what that
is.
Then understanding that there's
structure and discipline and that I am
in a lot of ways,
both of those things you described
earlier.
I'm in a lot of ways.
My mind is creative and I'm always a
sort of half paying attention to things,
but I'm also right and it's one of the
reasons why I think I'm.
I so relate to both sides of this issue
because I could have been one of the
reasons you're successful.
I could have easily been some hardcore
right wing asshole.
I'm a competition oriented person that
I've been since I was a child.
I grew up competing in martial arts
tournament.
I mean,
that's.
And you have to be a hard person to do
that.
You have to understand what discipline
is,
but before that I was an artist.
I wanted to be a cartoon it.
I wanted to do comic books.
That's what I wanted to do.
I wanted to be an illustrator.
If it wasn't for one bad teacher in high
school that totally shied me away from
art,
I probably would have went into that as
a,
as a living.
When I look at both sides,
I see myself in both sides.
Yep.
The other thing I've been telling young
men is that,
and this is something I think that you
could relate to tremendously as I read
this new testament line while it decades
ago,
and I could never understand it.
It's the lion is the meek shall inherit
the earth.
And I thought there's something wrong
with that.
That line,
it just doesn't make sense to me.
Meet just doesn't seem to me to be a
moral virtue.
And so I did a series of biblical
lectures this year,
like 15 of them and that was also a
weird little experience that we can talk
about,
but I was looking through the,
these,
these sayings,
these maximums and that was one of them.
The meek shall inherit the earth,
but I've been using this site called
bible hub and it's very interesting.
It's very organiZed,
very interesting.
So you have a biblical line and then
they.
They have like three pages of commentary
on each line and so because people have
commented on every verse in the bible
like to the two degree,
that's almost unimaginable.
So you can look and see all the
interpretations and all the translations
and get some sense of what the gen
genuine meaning might be and they line
the meek shall inherit the earth.
Meek is not a good translation or the
word has moved in the 300 years or so,
300 years or so since it was translated.
What it means is this,
those who have swords and know how to
use them but keep the machine will
inherit the world.
And that's another thing I've been
telling.
Yeah,
no kidding.
That's a big difference.
It's so great.
And so one of the things I tell young
men and young women as well,
but the young men really need to hear
this more,
I think is that you should be a monster.
You know,
because everyone says,
well,
you should be harmless.
Virtuous.
You shouldn't do anyone any harm.
You should sheath your competitive
instincts.
You shouldn't try to win.
You know,
you don't want to be too aggressive.
You don't want to be to assert.
If you want to take a back seat and all
of that,
it's like no wrong.
You should be a monster,
an absolute monster,
and then you should learn how to control
it.
Do you know the expression?
It's better to be a in a garden
than a gardener and award.
Right?
Exactly.
That's exactly it.
And that's exactly right.
And so when I tell young men that they
think,
well,
lots of them are competitive,
they're low in agreeableness,
you know,
because that's part of being competitive
temperamentally.
So because there's something wrong with
being competitive,
there's nothing wrong with it.
There's something wrong with cheating.
There's something wrong with being a
tyrant is something wrong with winning
unfairly.
All of those things are bad,
but you don't want people to win.
What's the difference between trying to
win and striving?
You want to eradicate striving.
What's the uncomfortable feeling that
people associate with losing when
they've personally experienced it?
They look at losing as they have.
They've been oppressed or they have been
heard,
but what they don't understand is that
as the motivation for growth and one of
the most beautiful things that I think a
young person can get involved in his
martial arts,
because martial arts teach you that in a
way that very few things do.
They teach you in,
especially jujitsu because jujitsu is so
complex and there's so many
possibilities to it that it attracts a
lot of really smart people.
If you think of jujitsu,
you would think of like brutish
individuals engaging in this hard
martial art.
If you go to a real good jujitsu school,
you see nerds,
you see a bunch of really smart kids
that really get obsessed with the
possibilities of this physical language.
This physical language also teaches you
the consequences of not working hard,
of not being prepared,
of not understanding positions of not
doing due diligence and doing the work,
and it's.
It's an amazing,
amazing scaffolding for developing your
life.
Teaches you how to lose.
Yes.
That's very important.
Definition of a winner is someone who
never let losing stop.
yes,
and the idea that a single loss in the
competition is somehow a defeat is
completely insane.
First of all,
well let's say you're a hockey player
and you're a good player and you.
You lose the tournament.
It's like,
well,
so what?
You played the game.
You're increasing your skills.
It's like there's always next time and
one of the things that I've also been
telling people,
informing people about is the idea that
life isn't a game.
It's a series of games and the right
ethic is to be the winner of the series
of games and part of that means you,
while you have learned how to be a good
loser because you're not gonna win every
single game,
but you also have to embrace those
losses as learning experiences and the
people that have never lost or afraid of
losing their afraid of learning.
You're afraid of That feeling of that
terrible feeling that you get from
losing is so beneficial.
It's aided me in so many ways,
like it's one of the reasons also one of
the reasons why I talk so openly about
bombing on stage and I'd do it with
other comedians.
I will always want to tell people,
yeah,
I'm an established comedian.
I've been in community for a long time.
Let me tell you about like when I was
two years in or five years in or,
or four years ago,
like can we tell you about some horrible
moments on stage where it went wrong so,
so you understand like those things took
me to another place because I realized I
don't want to ever feel that feeling
again.
And so I ramped everything up and then I
went back to work and I went over my
notebooks and I went over my,
my recordings and I figured out what I
was doing wrong and I tried to improve
upon it,
but if,
if it wasn't for that horrible sick
feeling,
that's the same feeling you get when you
get tapped out in jujitsu class.
Same feeling you geT when you lose a
martial arts tournament or anything
else.
Losing is important.
Well,
you might also say like,
let's say that you could pick your,
you can pick your level of competition
in life to some degree.
Okay,
so let's say you pick a level of
competition where you're always winning.
It's like,
well,
all that means is you've picked the
wrong level of competition because you
know,
like let's say you're a grand master
chess player and you're.
All you do is play amateurs and every
night you go home and congratulate
yourself and what a genius you are
because you just stomp these people
left,
right?
And center.
IT's like you're not a genius.
You're dimwit.
What you should be doing is playing
people who are beating you like,
well,
as much as you can tolerate.
So maybe that's 40 percent of the time.
Maybe it's 60 percent of the time,
but that way because to be a winner you
want to be disciplined.
You want to know what you're doing,
and then you want to be on the edge
where your skills are being developed
and if you're going to be on the edge
where your skills are going to be
developed,
you're.
You're at a place where we're lost.
We're losing is always a possibility
because otherwise you're not pushing
yourself beyond your current capacity,
and so one of the things that I've
outlined in 12 rules for life,
this is a theory of Meaning because
meaning,
as far as I'm concerned,
that sense of meaningful engagement is
the antidote to malevolence and
suffering essentially because you want
to have a life that's so engaging that
you think despite the fact that I'm
limited and that we're mortal and that
life is tragedy and there's evil in the
world despite all that this is worth
doing,
and I think that that there's.
There's a.
There's a technical meaning that,
that that genuinely exists and that's
the meaning that you get when you're in
a domain where you have some discipline
and some skill,
so you're laying out your competence and
your your ability,
but you're simultaneously pushing
yourself to develop past where you are.
That's reallY engrossing and what's that
do it.
What did that is doing is expanding your
competence and so life is suffering and
betrayal in,
in,
in many senses of the word.
but you can adopt a way of traversing
through life that is more powerful than
the tragedy in the malevolence.
I agree and I say to many people that
what?
What is going on in your life as you
have a series of human reward systems
that are in your body and coded in your
body and your genetics,
and it's the reason why human beings
survive to 2018,
and in order to be happy,
you have to feed those things.
You have to feed all of them.
You have to feed the one that Wants to
overcome difficult tasks.
You have to feed the one that wants to
solve problems.
be with a loving tribe of people that
you care about.
You have to feed the one that wants to
procreate.
You have to feed all of these things.
You have to feed the love.
You have to feed the competition.
You have to feed the discipline,
and that to me is the only way to stay
balanced or with me,
with my body and my mind.
That's the only way of I've been able to
stay balanced and when either any of
those things get out of whack,
I get.
Yeah,
well,
so.
So part of that is so imagine this,
so imagine that you're this loose
collection of all these things that need
to be gratified that needed to be fed.
It's a perfectly reasonable way of
looking at it biologically.
Okay,
so now you have to conJure up a mode of
being that satisfies all those
necessities simultaneously.
But then,
and this is,
this is a technical explanation of why
the postmodernist insistence that
there's an infinite number of
explanations turns out to be wrong,
an infinite number of interpretations.
There's a very finite number of viable
interpretations.
So the first constraint is what exactly
what you just said.
You have these inner demons,
let's say,
all of which need to be satisfied,
but they need to be satisfied in a very
particular way.
Not only do they need to be satisfied
today,
but they need to be satisfied today in a
way that doesn't interfere with
satisfying the next week,
next month,
next year,
in a decade.
So because there's no point in you
betraying your future self to gratify
your present self,
it's a stupid game.
Okay,
so you're constrained by the necessity
of satisfying yourself,
but of maintaining that satisfaction
across time,
but then it gets even more.
That's hard enough,
but it's like there's an infinite number
of use extending indefinitely into the
future and all of them have to be
satisfied simultaneously.
But then it's worse because it isn't
just you.
You have to figure out how to gratify
all those internal demons in a
sustainable way,
in a way that other people not only
don't object to,
but probably help you with and that
benefits them at the same time.
Well then you think you think while
there just aren't that many ways of
solving that problem and we know some of
them,
one of them is reciprocity.
You know,
like if you go out of your way,
for me it's incumbent on me to notice
that and to attempt in some manner to,
to repay you.
And like if,
if we're good friends,
that's what we'll do.
If we're a good brothers,
That's what you do with your wife.
It's a reciprocal arrangement and that
keeps things flowing properly across
time.
So there is on,
there is an ethic this and this is the
answer to the postmodern conundrums
like,
well his life meaningless because
everything just nihilist is nihilism.
The right answer or maybe you know the.
What would you call identification with
an ideology as a counter position to
nihilism.
So nihilism is wrong,
life is meaningful.
That and that's what 12 rules for life
is about.
The first meaning of life is suffering
and malevolence is indisputable
realities.
Okay,
well what's,
what's after that?
While there's a noBle way of being that
allows you to exist properly despite
that and also not to make it worse,
so can your life be meaningful enough so
that you.
What is it?
Confront chaos voluntarily establishing,
revivify order
constrained malevolence.
That's a good three part doctrine for
life.
There's things to do and so that's what
I've been talking to the audiences that
I've been seeing over the last year.
It's like get your act together,
stand up forthrightly.
That's rule one.
Stand up straight with your shoulders
back.
There's a vulnerable position,
right,
because you're open,
but it's a powerful position because it
means that you're brave enough to take
what's coming and it isn't like what's
coming isn't dangerous.
It's dangerous,
so,
but your best bet is to be dancing on
your feet and ready for it to pay
attention and be awake and to treat
yourself property.
That's rule two is figuring out how to
treat yourself as if you're soMeone
worth coming to the aid of to detach
yourself in a bit and say,
okay,
I'm going to set up my life so that it.
It's good for me and good for other
people as well.
As a corollary to that.
So the book is all about all about
the meanings of life,
the negative meanings,
suffering,
malevolence.
Those are indisputable realities and
then a mode of being that integrates the
sorts of things that you were talking
about,
these underlying needs with everyone
else's and like doing that voluntarily.
It's a call to responsibility and
meaning and I actually think it's not.
The thing that's been so exciting for me
for the last three decades looking into
these things is that I believe that
there is a genuine human ethic.
It's not arbitrary.
It has to do with reciprocity,
for exampLe,
has to do with honesty.
That's another thing is that you speak
the truth because your life turns out
better if you speak the truth,
and so does everyone else's.
So in this biblical lecture series I
did,
I looked at the first chapter in genesis
and there's a theory in there.
It's really interesting theory and the
theory is that there's three parts to
being.
There's chaos and potential and that
would be like the potential you should
live up to because everyone says,
well,
you should live up to your potential.
It's like,
what the hell is that?
you can't measure it or touch it or
taste it,
feel it.
It's this hypothetical thing that
everyone regardless real.
it's like it's like the future.
What's the future?
What's not here yet?
You can't measure it but makes you think
it's real.
Well,
we act as if it's real and that seems to
work.
There's the po,
so there's potential that's one that's
chaos,
chaotic potential.
Then there's order and that's the
structure that you need in order to to
confront the chaos and and you'd be born
with that biologically and then there's
your ability to to call forth from the
potential new order and that's what you
do with your speech.
That's what.
That's what happens in the first chapter
of genesis is that god uses god order,
let's say,
uses the power of truthful speech.
That's the logos to transform potential
into order and that's what people are
made in the image of.
So there's this theory.
It's a lovely theory that's laid out
right at the beginning of the that says
that if you tell the truth,
you transformed the potential of being
into a habitable actuality.
That's how it works.
So say,
well,
how do you want it?
how do you make the world better?
Tell the truth,
because the world you bring into being
as a consequence of telling the truth
will be a good world,
and I believe that's true.
I think it's true.
Metaphorically.
I think it's true theologically and I
think it's true like at the practical
and scientific level as well.
I think it's true in all those levels
simultaneously.
That's been ridiculously exciting too to
sort through.
I think this notion,
and one of the things that you said that
I think really resonates is that there's
not a voice out there that is advocating
for responsibility and that is talking
about how important this is and I think
this is an inherent principle that most
people are kind of aware of and it feels
good to them to hear like it resonates.
So you feel it.
You,
when you,
when you're saying this,
clean your room,
you know,
put your house in order.
People like,
yeah,
I'll come.
I'm not hearing this.
Right.
I'm not hearing them.
Well,
it's so funny because one of the things
psychologists have done for the last 20
years,
especially the social psychologist,
has pushed this idea of self esteem.
You should feel good about yourself now
I think,
why would you tell someone 20 that It's
like,
you should feel good about who you are.
It's like,
no,
you shouldn't.
Why should you feel good about who you
are?
It's like you should feel good about who
you could be.
That's way better because you got 60
years to turn into who you could wait a
minute.
are you what your accomplishments are or
you descend individual going through
this journey.
I mean,
I don't think there's anything wrong
with feeling good about who you are as
long as it's tempered by an
understanding of potential and what you
have accomplished versus what you can
occur,
but having confidence is a big part in
it is.
It is,
and I'm not saying that people shouldn't
have confidence,
but like often you take young people say
there are 16 to 22 and they're not
really feeling not good about who they
are because their life is chaotic and in
disorder and they don't know where
they're going and they don't know which
way is up call.
So that could be bad parenting.
We get to be a lot of abuse going on and
I think that's one of the.
This is why that resonates with people.
This idea of be happy for you about who
you are.
Right?
Feel good about who you are,
but but the thing is,
it has to be stated with precision.
It's like,
yes,
it's like you should.
You should treat yourself as if you're
valuable,
especially in potential,
but you should concentrate on who you
should become,
especially if you're young,
and so let's say you're miserable and
nihilistic and chaotic and depressed and
all of that now,
and you have your reasons,
you know,
terrible parenting abuse,
all of those things.
It's like,
well,
you should feel good about yourself.
It's like,
no,
it's not.
It's not the right message is that it's
more like you should understand how much
potentIal there is within you to set
that straight and then you should do
everything you can to manifest that in
the world and it will set it straight
and that's better than self esteem.
It's like you're,
you're in a crooked,
horrible position.
Okay,
fine.
There's a lot of suffering and pain
associated with that.
Yeah,
you can't just feel good about that
because it's not good,
but you can do something about it.
You can genuinely do something about it,
and I think all the evidence suggests
that that's the case.
Yes,
so I'm telling,
telling young people,
look,
there's no Matter how bad your situation
is,
I'm not going to pretend it's okay.
It's not okay.
It's tragic,
tainted with malevolence,
and some people really get hurt by
malevolent people like you know,
terribly hurt.
Sometimes they never recover.
It's really awful,
but there's more to you than you think,
and if you stand up and face it with,
with a positive,
with a,
with a noble vision,
with discipline and intent,
you can go far farther to overcoming it.
Then you can imagine and that's the
principal upon which you should
predicate your behavior.
And I think that one of the things
that's really nice about being a
clinical psychologist is that this isn't
just guesswork.
Like one of the things we know,
two things in clinical psychology,
one is truthful conversations,
redeem people.
Because if you come to a clinical
psychologist who's worth his salt,
you have a truthful conversation.
The conversation is,
well,
here's what's wrong with my life and
here's what caused it.
You know,
maybe it takes a year to have that
conversation and both of the
participants are doing everything they
can to lay it out properly.
Here's how it might be fixed,
here's what a beneficial future might
look like.
And so it's a completely honest
conversation if it's working well.
And all that's happening in the
conversation is that the two people
involved are trying to make things
better.
That's the goal.
Let's see if we can have a conversation
that will make things better.
okay?
So we know that works.
It does make things better.
And then another thing we know is that,
well,
let's say there's a bunch of things that
you're afraid of that are in your way.
So you have some vision about who you
want to be.
Maybe you have to,
you know,
you want to be successful in your
career,
so you have to learn to talk in front of
a group.
It's like,
okay,
well you're afraid of that,
so no wonder you don't want to be
humiliated.
So okay,
so what do we do about that?
Well,
maybe we first get you to speak in front
of one person and then three people for
five minutes and then for 10 minutes,
like graduated exposure to what you're
afraid of,
voluntary graduated exposure to what
you're afraid of is curative,
and that's true.
It works.
That documentation is in.
It's how people learn,
so,
so to to to tell people that if you
confront the world forthrightly,
if you speak the truth and you expose
yourself courageously to those things
that you're afraid of,
that your life will improve and so will
the life of people around you like as
far as I'm concerned,
that's as close to undeniable fact as
we've as we've got,
and it also dovetails nicely with the
underlying archetypal stories,
that heroic stories.
It's like go out there,
find the dragon confronted.
It's a dragon.
It might eat you.
It's dangerous,
but it's worse to cower at home and wait
for it to come and devour you.
Go out there confronted,
get the gold,
share it with the community.
It's like,
yeah,
it's the oldest story of mankind.
I think one of the factors in the
resistance to these ideas of discipline
and
of taking responsibility for yourself
and have a lot of the things that you've
been saying in regards to,
you know,
all the things that we discussed earlier
is people recognizing that they're not
doing that in their own lives and they
get upset and instead of looking
internally,
they tried to attack the thing that's
upsetting them.
They attack your message,
they attack the philosophy behind it.
Rather than look internally and
objectively and having some sort of
introspective point of view where you
go,
okay,
am I reacting to this because this is
resonates like I'm missing this aspect
of my life?
Is this guy does,
does,
does this diminish me?
Or is this guy pointing something out
that I can benefit from?
Very few people are willing to do that.
Very few people are willing to take that
critical moment to look at their own
behavior and look at their own thought
process and wonder if the actual adverse
reaction they have to this person's
message is because they know that
they're wrong.
Yeah.
Well,
it's.
No,
There's a couple of reasons for that.
One is,
well,
what makes you think that you're someone
we should listen to me.
It's like,
hey,
fair enough.
You know,
so you've got to be poked a bunch to see
if that's true.
And then the next thing is,
um,
well it's,
it's painful to understand how much of
what you're doing isn't productive.
So I'll givE you an example.
So I've done this a couple of times with
classrooms full of students.
Usually when I'm lecturing about career
deVelopment,
say,
okay,
um,
how much time do you waste?
So then I get the class to vote.
How many of you waste 10 hours a day?
It's like 10 percent of the kids that
put up their hands.
And it's interesting because I don't
define what constitutes waste.
I just asked the question.
So they're diagnosing themselves,
right?
I'm not saying you're wasting 10 hours a
day,
I'm just asking.
It's like given your own attitude,
how much time you're wasting 10 hours a
day.
It's like 10 percent of the people put
up their hands.
Well,
when you get to like six hours a day,
80 percent of the people put up their
hands,
so then we do the arithmetic.
It's because I like doing arithmetic
with people.
People hate arithmetic,
but I like doing it.
It's like,
okay,
six hours a day,
42 hours a week,
so let's call that a work week,
40 hours a week.
So,
so that's,
that's a work week.
Let's say what's your time worth,
your university student?
Or certainly worth minimum wage because
obviously,
but it's worth way more than that
because if you spend a productive hour
when you're 20 than you gain the
benefits of that hour for the rest of
your life.
So there's the compounding effect of
time spent when we were young.
So I say,
well,
let's assume your time is worth 50 bucks
an hour,
which I think is an underestimate,
but whatever.
Let's call it 50.
We call it 25,
but we'll call it 50.
That's $2,000
a week.
You're wasting $100,000
a year.
It's like,
how much better would your life be if
you weren't wasting $100,000
a year?
It's like,
what is that?
Over 40 years,
$4,000,000.
It's like you're rich.
You don't even know it.
Quit wasting time by your own
definition.
It's like people shake their heads like,
oh,
I never thought about it that way.
It's like,
yeah,
think about it that way.
Don't waste your damn life.
And then you think,
well,
why would people be resistant to that
message?
It's like,
well,
you really want to wake up and figure
out that you're wasting half your life
and you know,
when people do that kind of wasting,
they actually hate it.
You know,
and I've had lots of people come to my
clinical practice who were chronic
procrastinators,
you know,
and so they're watching youtube videos
say,
but,
but not ones that are good for them,
although sometimes they will do that,
but just browsing in that kind of
mindless way that you do when you're not
paying attention and you're trying to
kill time and people doing that,
they feel bad,
they get depressed,
they feel anxious,
they can't get away from it.
They feel kind of [inaudible] addicted.
Do saying about social media now.
It's a huge issue with young kids.
Absolutely,
but there's this feeling of kind of
internal wrought and corruption that
goes along with it.
It's like,
yeah,
well you're wasting your life.
It's like,
so it's painful.
It's painful to recognize that.
Then it's painful to think,
oh my god,
look how undisciplined I am.
I don't know anything.
I can't use a schedule.
I can't,
I can't stick to a calendar.
I don't have any aims.
I don't know anything about the world.
Right.
And maybe there's a part of me that's
bitter because I haven't got everything
already and I'd just like to say to hell
with it.
That's the recognition of the union
shadow.
So like that's what makes you a vicious
and,
and untrustworthy all of that.
No one wants to look at that and no
bloody wonder.
But hey,
the alternative is worse.
So the problem is you say like just
saying stop wasting your life.
Like I think that that's not enough.
I think this is one of the reasons why a
book like this is so important.
Like the idea of discipline and most
people's eyes is like,
if you're not a disciplined person,
it's uncomfortable.
It's going to be painful.
It's frustrating.
You have to force yourself into these
things.
It's a muscle.
It's a muscle that it has to be
developed.
These patterns have to be developed in
your own mind.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well with,
uh,
so you're right,
just telling people not to waste their
lives is not enough.
And this is another reason why I've so
much enjoyed being a clinical
psychologist because clinical
psychologists don't stick with high
level abstractions,
especially the behaviors.
They're really practical.
It's like,
okay,
you want to get your act together.
It's like,
well,
how about if let's say you're not
studying well,
and so we do a real analysis of how much
you're studying.
You say,
well,
I go to the library for hours a day.
It's like,
yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
How much time do you actually study in
the library?
Well,
you know,
I waste time.
I have to travel there.
I look at my phone,
it's like,
okay,
well how much?
Fifteen minutes,
half an hour.
How much is real studying?
While maybe we figure out it's 15
minutes,
say,
okay,
so what are you going to do for one week
is you're going to study for half an
hour.
That's all.
You don't get to go to the library for
four hours,
you have to sit down and we'll figure
out a time,
10:00
in the morning,
whatever.
We'll put it in your schedule,
try to study for an hour no more and
then just come back and let's have a
conversation about how well that worked
and people will come back and they say,
well,
you know,
I managed it for days and one day I went
over and one day I couldn't do it at
all.
It's like,
okay,
that's better.
Instead of 75 minutes of studying,
you know,
15 minutes a day for seven days,
what is that?
15,
7,105
minutes.
You've managed about 210 minutes,
so you've already produced an
improvement of 50 percent and your
bumbling,
horrible way.
You've got a 50 percent improvement in
one week.
It's like that's deadly.
It's like so in the future authoring
program,
what we ask people to do is we'll think
about your life along six dimensions.
What do you want for your,
so the goal is this,
you're going to take care of yourself,
you're going to have a life in three
years that justifies its suffering.
That's the goal,
so you can invent the damn life,
but you have to think what you would be
satisfied with so you wouldn't be all
bitter and resentful.
It's like,
okay,
what do you want from your family?
What do you want from your friends?
How are you going to educate yourself?
What do you want for your career?
How are you going to use your time
outside of work?
How are you going to handle drugs and
alcohol and other temptations like that?
How are we going to keep yourself
mentally and physically healthy?
These are open questions like you get to
answer the.
The idea is you can have whatever you
want,
but you have to figure out what it is.
It has to be realistic and you have to
figure out what it is.
So okay,
so now develop a vision.
What's your life going to be like in
three to five years,
so we write it down.
Then we do something else,
which is,
okay,
I'm your bad habits and your resentment
and your bitterness and all of that.
Your procrastination gets completely out
of hand and you auger down and you're in
your own personal version of hell in
three to five years.
What does that look like?
Well,
everyone knows that.
It'S like everyone can look into the
future and think,
well,
if I keep going on this dark path,
this is where I'll end up.
Well then you've got little hail outline
for yourself to run away from and you
got a little heaven outline for yourself
to run towards and then you're motivated
because sometimes you know,
you're just hopeful.
I would like a good thing to happen.
It's like,
yeah,
but you know,
I'd like to drink half a bottle of
whiskey tonight too.
It's like,
so which is it going to be?
Well,
just being hopeful about the future
might not be enough,
but then you think,
oh,
I see.
Like there's that little health thing
that I outlined this waiting for me and
maybe I'm afraid of taking the next step
forward because it's demanding and
challenging.
It's like,
yeah,
I'm afraid of that,
but I'm way more afraid of where I might
end up if I don't get my act together
and people should be.
That's why their conceptions of hell and
so many religions,
it's like hell is a real place.
Whether it's eternal.
That's a whole different question.
Whether it's waiting for you in the
afterlife.
That's a whole different question,
but if you'Ve never met anyone in hell,
you haven't lived very long.
You haven't had your eyes open.
Yeah.
It's undeniable the,
the,
the feeling of total complete misery.
Undeniable.
Yeah.
Especially when it's compounded by the
fact that you know,
you did it to yourself.
That's real fun.
That's the real fun part.
It's like I'm having a bitch of a time
and I richly deserve it.
Jesus,
that's rough,
man.
This is another concept that is doesn't
have a right now.
This is another.
I mean,
this is a giant part of being human
being and instead of identity politics
and right versus left,
I think these,
these right versus left battles
oftentimes what they are as a simply the
battle ground for the conflicts in your
own mind.
Yep,
yep.
Better to have the conflict in yourself.
That's another thing I really learned.
Well,
not not only from the new testament,
but a fair bit from that.
No.
The idea is that,
well,
there's evil in the world of all sorts
and some of it's evil and other people
and some of it's the evil in your
brother's heart,
but the part of it that you can really
do something about that's the
malevolence in your own heart.
You can actually do something about that
and that's actually way more useful than
you think,
so because if you can face it in you,
then you start to understand it and that
also makes you strong enough to identify
it and to fight it.
When you see it in the external world,
plus you don't do any harm.
It's like like there's lots of people
all over the world going out and doing
reprehensible things and you might say,
well,
you should go out and protest against
them like then sometimes you should,
but most of the time you should think,
where am I falling short of the ideal,
my own ideal.
It doesn't have to be one that someone
puts on you.
Where am I less than I should be?
Where am I bitter?
Where am I making the world a worse
place than it has to be?
Like you ask yourself those questions.
You'll be in for a big shock to say,
well,
what would happen if you stopped doing
that?
That's what 12 rules for life is about.
It's like stop saying things that make
you weak.
Stop telling lies that you know to be
lies,
stopped doing things you know,
to be useless and counterproductive.
Aim high dobson responsibility and then
see what the hell happens so I can work
and that's what I'm hoping people will
do.
Yeah,
I'm hoping people will do that too.
And I think if more people live their
life in this sort of a manner,
I think we're going to have less
differences in terms of our ideologies
and more of an understanding that people
have different ways of looking at things
in different ways of living and this,
this combat between people,
this,
this internal strife that manifests
itself in this combat between
ideologies.
I think you are much more inclined to
let other people live their lives if
you're living your life in a
satisfactory manner.
That that's exactly it.
That's that.
I have a chapter in there
raising kids says,
don't like your kids.
Don't let your kids do anything.
It makes you dislike them.
It's like,
well,
that's first predicated on the
observation that you're quite a monster
and it would be better for your kids if
they didn't get on your bad side.
And again,
because I'm a clinical psychologist
monster.
Why?
Why do you use that term?
Because I've watched families,
like I've seen families where it's as if
every single person in the family has
their hands around the neck of the
family member that's close to them and
they're squeezing.
But only tight enough to strangle the
been 20 years.
But you're not always using it as a
pejorative.
You,
you,
you've also used it.
You should become a monster.
You should be a monster.
Yeah.
But that's.
You shouldn't be.
It shouldn't be accidental.
That's the thing.
What?
So what do you mean by monster then?
In a positive sense?
Like you should be a monster.
Oh,
that's easy.
Amman,
a positive monster is somebody who says
no and means it.
Because when you say know what you mean
is there isn't anything you can do to me
that will make me agree to do this.
Why is that a monster?
Because you have to be because no one
will take you seriously.
Otherwise no one will take you
seriously.
Like no means if you keep pushing this
something that you do not like will
happen to you.
That's what no means.
You don't have any strength of character
unless you can put up a fight,
you know?
And to be able to say no to something is
to be able to put up a fight.
So when you can't do that,
if you're,
if you can be pushed around,
you'll just get argued into submission
or you'll feel guilty because you're
causing conflict or something like that.
But isn't there confusion using those
terms as a positive,
as a negative?
Maybe there's another
word instead of monster.
Well there is.
There is the potential.
There is the potential for confusion.
You say,
well,
is that something that can be
[inaudible]?
I think that
monster is a horrible thing.
I don't think of it as being like a
wall,
like someone who is just rock solid in
their belief system and rock solid and
their understanding of when you fight
someone who's formidable say what do you
think of the person that you're
fighting?
Like how would you characterize them?
They may have a monster side because
they can take,
they can,
they can bring physical,
substantial physical force to bear on
the situation and and be willing to do
it so they're not naive and and harmless
by any stretch of the imagination.
Right?
They have a well developed capacity for
mayhem.
You think,
well,
is that monstrous?
It's like,
well,
I would say yes,
I would say fierce.
Fierce,
fine,
let's go with that.
Yeah.
Because someone who's fierce and
formidable,
it's not necessarily a monster,
you know,
just I think of a monster as being just
an awful person who's done awful things
and just,
you know.
Okay,
well,
so be fair,
fair enough.
Well,
so back to tHe back to the issue
situation with your kids while you
definitely don't want to have your kids
act in a way that awakens your inner
monster,
let's put it that way.
And so you need to.
You need to organize your family with a
certain amount of discipline and a
certain amount of structure so that you
get to do what you want,
which is back to back to the point that
you made earlier so that you're happy to
have your kids around so that you won't
take revenge on them.
and so you want to lay your life out so
that well,
so that it's providing you what you need
to not be bitter and to work for your
best interests and for the interests of
everyone else.
That would be lovely and I think it's
attainable,
you know,
because the book is very dark and I'm a
very dark guy in some ways because I've
looked at the terrible things that
people do to one another.
That's
a fascinating way of looking at.
If you think you're yourself as dark
because I don't think of you as dark.
Oh,
that's good.
You seem very friendly guy.
I think you're.
You're very serious and especially about
these very complicated issues and I
think that's one of the reasons why you
have made this gigantic wave in online
discourse.
People discussing these very tumultuous
times that we live in is because you're
a guy that did extrapolate.
Your guy did look at that [inaudible]
bill and look at marxism and go,
do you know where this is headed?
And you were the guy that had the
courage to say murderous and,
and people are like,
what the fuck is he talking about?
That doesn't make any sense.
And you had to spell it out and explain
it.
And when you do you realize why this is
so significant to you?
Yeah.
Well,
the,
the tRibalism issue that you were
discussing earlier,
it doesn't seem to be all of that.
What would you say?
Debatable that if we degenerate into
tribalism,
the probability of bloodshed becomes
vastly enhanced.
IT's like,
well,
that always happens when people devolve
into tribalism.
So,
and I'm pointing to a particular kind of
tribalism.
I guess the darkness is that,
you know,
I'm Very aware of the terrible things
that people not only are likely to do to
each other,
but do,
do to each other all the time.
I mean,
what?
It's about 40 percent for divorce rate.
Right?
But you to go through a fairly fair bit
of ugliness to get to divorce.
Canadians are nicer than americans.
Maybe you guys are 40 percent maybe.
Maybe.
I think it's fairly similar to the
present.
I think actually it's 50 percent here,
somewhere on that one,
but yeah.
Yeah,
you have to go through a lot.
That's really ugly to,
you know,
and chris rock had a joke about that and
he's like,
50 percent of people get divorced.
He goes,
hey.
but that's just the people who had the
courage to leave.
He goes,
how many cowards just stay and suffer,
and meanwhile he wound up getting
divorced a few years later.
Right.
Horrible divorce.
So yeah.
True story.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But it's a good point.
Yeah.
I think,
um,
we need more people who were actualized
human beings,
more and more people who understand
themselves,
more people who have gone through
adversity both in real life and personal
in terms of their understanding of their
own growth,
of their own potential and their own
understanding of how they've managed
their life,
their mind,
their,
their actions.
And the more we have people that have
personal sovereignty,
the better we'll be able to have these
conversations.
Well that,
that'd be the hope.
You know,
one of the things I've been suggesting
to people is that they pick something
difficult to do.
I rEad this is funny,
little paragraph by kierkegaard.
It was written in about 1840 and he was
thinking about his role as a student and
writer and he was a student in writer
forever,
you know,
he never really had a career apart from
that.
And he said that he wasn't one of these
people who was capable of inventing
something wonderful to make life easier
for everyone.
Like so many people were doing it during
the industrial revolution.
He said,
well,
maybe I'm one of these whose benefit to
society will be that I will make things
more difficult for everyone because
there will come a time when what people
want not.
They don't want ease,
they want difficulty instead.
And I think,
well,
that is what people want.
That is what they want.
You think,
well,
I want an easy,
happy life.
It's like,
no,
actually that isn't what you want a see
wonderful bond is things that are
difficult that they can overcome.
Yeah,
right.
That's right.
They want an optimal challenge as a
whole different thing when you overcome
something,
when you do something difficult,
whether it's.
I mean,
I've never written a book,
but I assume when you write a book,
when you're done writing that book,
there's a great feeling of
accomplishment because it's very
difficult to do that feeling of
accomplished.
For me,
it's like when I put together a comedy
special or when I,
you know,
just anything that's difficult,
there's a feeling like I did it.
Yeah.
Well,
one of the mysteries is why that feeling
exists,
you know,
it's a genuine.
It's not a trivial thing that it's to
say I did something difficult and that
was worthwhile.
Basically what you're saying to yourself
as well,
there was a lot of suffering attendant
on that along with the just general
suffering of life,
but it turned out that was worth it.
That's what you want is like you want
that sense that you're engaged in
something that's worth it.
And I say,
well,
like I,
I try to.
I'm not a like a casual optimist about
these sorts of things.
I mean,
one of the things I do in 12 rules for
life is lay out the rationale that
drives people like to call them by in
high school killers.
Because I understand that rationale.
I've studied it for a long time.
I know why they did what they did and
they have a powerful argument,
but it's wrong,
but you don't.
There's no sense in showing how it's
wrong before showing that it's a
powerful argument like light life is
suffering.
There is lots of malevolence.
It's no wonder that people want to bring
being itself to a halt.
They want to take revenge on.
It's not surprising.
It's the wrong way of going about it.
The right way is it's akin to the sorts
of things that you were just observing
as you take on a difficult task that
pushes you past where you are already
and you,
you succeed in it and you get this sense
that yes,
that was worthwhile.
It's like that's what you want.
You want to live in that place where
things are worthwhile.
That's paradise on earth.
That's what that is and it isn't some
happy little place where you know
someone's feeding,
you peeled grapes.
That isn't what it is.
It's.
It's more like.
It's more like victory on the honorable
battlefield or something like that.
You have the perception that people have
of ultimate success and ultimate
happiness is a.
It seems motivated by what they don't
have rather than an understanding of
what success and happiness really is.
Their their ideas at one day I'm going
to go and I'm going to be in my golden
years and I'm just going to be able to
sit around and do nothing until
everybody to fuck off.
You won't be happy.
I know I talked to two to one of the
people that I was working with who had a
vision for retirement.
I said,
well,
what's your vision for retirement?
Well,
I see myself in a beach,
you know,
some tropical country drinking
margaritas.
And I thought,
first,
that's not a plan,
that's a travel posters.
It's like,
okay,
let's,
let's walk through this.
All right,
so you go down to this tropical country
and he goes,
sit on the beach and you have a
margarita.
It's like,
okay,
well how many margarita is like 10.
Okay,
so gonna do that.
We're going to do that for six months.
You'll be dead.
Yeah.
Well you'll be this like pathetic,
sunburned,
like fat unhappy.
Hung over surrounding.
Yeah.
It's like,
that's your vision.
So how long can you have a margarita on
the beach?
Like maybe you can do that once every
six months for like 10 minutes,
something like that.
It's not a vision,
it's true.
But when you are working and slaving
away,
you think about that beach with your
feet up and the waiter comes over.
Would you like another margarita Mr.
Peterson?
Yes,
I would absolutely ready.
Exactly.
But it's like this 16 year old fantasy
of paradise.
It's like,
well,
and it just doesn't work out.
So the thing that,
the thing is is that the thing that
sustains people through life really is
the lifting of a worthwhile burden.
It's something like that and it's partly
because we're social animals,
right?
It's like we're evolved to be useful to
the people around us because they're
much more likely to let us live if we're
like that.
So and,
and it's been very fun talking to
especially talking to young men about
this.
It's like,
well now it's.
The other thing too is I think the
world,
the world is full of darkness,
let's say.
And we could say each of us have a
little bit of light,
and if we released that light,
if we let it shine properly,
christ,
it's too cliched to go on with in some
sense,
but the world is a lesser place if you
do not reveal from within yourself what
you have to reveal.
And the fact that the world is a lesser
place actually turns out not to be
trivial.
Like if you aren't everything,
you could be more.
People will die,
more people will suffer,
more evil will be unconstrained,
more tyranny will reign,
more chaos will remain chaotic and
dangerous.
All of that.
Do you mean this by this?
In the sense of like the old proverb of
the wings of a butterfly fluttering
become a hurricane.
It's,
it's something similar to that,
but it can even be more local.
It's like your family is more messed up
than it could be if you were less messed
up than you are.
Right?
So if you just got your act together
like 10 percent more,
your family would be one percent better.
So like,
well do it and that would ripple off.
And people that they interact and it
ripples fast.
That's the other thing that's so cool is
that like people think,
well there's 7 billion of us and each of
us is just this separate dust mote like
floating in the cosmos and what the hell
difference does it make what you do
anyways?
It's like,
that is not how we're connected.
It's like you're the center of a network
and you know,
well you know,
way more people than this,
but let's say typically you know,
a thought,
you're going to know a thousand people
in your life well enough to have an
impact on them.
Okay?
And each of those thousand people is
going to know a thousand people.
So you're one step from a million and
two steps from a billion.
And we are network technically that
that's how human work.
And so when you do something that you
shouldn't do,
it's worse than you think.
And when you do something that you
should do,
it's better than you think.
And so you think,
well this is why I've been telling
people will clean up your room.
It's like,
well,
your room is actually network to.
It's not that easy to clean up your room
to set it,
so you want your room to be set up so
that when you walk in there,
it tells you to be better than you
generally are.
It's organized,
it's got direction,
everything's in its place.
He tried to do that in a chaotic
household.
You know,
I've watched people do this because I
had students do these sorts of things as
assignments.
I'd say,
look,
pick us small moral goal,
clean up your room and just write down
what happens as a consequence.
So maybe these are students in a chaotic
household.
the whole place is a bloody mess.
No one's taking any responsibility for
anything,
and so they decided they're going to
start to clean up their room and then
the people in the household notice,
well,
the first thing they do is get pissed
off.
IT's like,
who do you think you are like,
you think you're better than us.
It's like,
why do you think this is worthwhile?
Who made,
who died and made you god?
All of that.
So just by trying to organize this
little part of their life,
they immediately run into the people
whose actions they're casting in a dim
light by trying to improve themselves to
some degree.
They might have to have like a thorough
war in their household to be allowed to
do something as simple as keeping the
room orderly.
They find out very rapidly that a,
that's way more difficult than it sounds
and be that the consequences of it are
far more far reaching than people think.
So that's quite fun,
you know,
because maybe part of it is,
is that like everything around you is
full of potential.
Everything maybe more potential than you
could ever possibly utilize.
And so maybe all you have is this little
rat hole of a room and some rundown
place in the world.
It's like fix it up.
There's more there than you think.
See what happens if you fix it up and
you'll fix yourself up.
Cymbalta obviously because you have to
get disciplined in order to fix up the
room and then you have a fixed up room
and you'll be a more fixed up person.
IT's like you think that nothing will
happen as a consequence of that.
It's like all hell will break loose as a
consequence of that.
That's really worth trying.
It is worth trying and it's a concept
that seems alien to people,
but if you think about it,
it makes sense.
Well,
people don't take what they have right
in front of them,
seriously enough.
It's like the wasting time thing.
They don't do the arithmetic,
you know,
and they also don't understand.
They devalue what they have right in
front of them.
Like another,
another client I worked with was having
a hard time putting his kid to bed at
night and so we did the arithmetic.
It's like,
well I'm fighting with my kid for 45
minutes a night trying to get him to go
to bed.
Okay,
so let,
let's analyze that.
Alright,
so what does that mean?
Well,
it means that both of you end the day
upset.
That's not so good because why would you
want that?
It means that you're spending 45 minutes
fighting when you could spend 20 minutes
doing something positive.
Like reading to him say means that you
don't get to spend that time with your
wife so she's not very happy with you.
Plus you're annoyed because you don't
see here.
Plus you blame it on the kid because the
proximal cause it's like that's pretty
damn ugly and then,
and then let's do the arithmetic.
It's like seven days a week,
45 minUtes a day.
Let's call that five hours.
Twenty hours a week,
240 hours in a year six,
you're spending a month and a half of
work weeks fighting with your four year
old son.
You think you're going to like them.
You don't like anyone.
You spend a month and a half a year
fighting with.
It's a bad idea.
Fix it.
It's important.
Get them to bed,
make it peaceful.
you do it like these things that repeat
every single day.
That's a motif in this Book to your
life.
Isn't margarita is on a beach in Jamaica
that happens now in that those are
exceptions you're life is how your wife
greets you at the door when you come
home every day because that's like 10
minutes a day.
Your life is how you treat each other
over the breakfast table because that's
an hour and a half or an hour every
single day.
You get those mundane things,
right?
Those things you do everyday,
you concentrated on them and you make
them pristine.
It's like you got 80 percent of your
life put together.
These little things that are right in
front of us.
They're not little.
That's the first thing.
They are not little and they're hard to
set.
Right,
and if you set them right,
it has a rippling effect and fast to way
faster than people think.
I want to talk about the rippling effect
because I know you've got to get out of
here at one,
but I want to talk about the rippling
effect that you have had on people and
how how that makes you feel.
I mean,
you were relatively unknown just a year
and a half,
two years ago and now you have become,
I mean for lack of a better term,
you're an online celebrity and your,
your reaches.
Fantastic.
Now this thing that you were talking
about about how your impact can affect
the people around you in a not very,
a not insignificant way,
a very significant way.
What has that been like for you?
I mean,
what does that adjustment than like just
I haven't adjusted to it.
How old are you?
Fifty five.
So for 53 years.
You're relatively anonymous.
Other outside of uni
versus.
Yeah.
I had a little bit of,
a little bit of exposure.
I did some work with a public television
station in Canada and I had my little
flashes of public appearances that sort
of crazy.
What you've done on thIs show mean
millions,
millions.
People have listened and watched each,
each,
each individual episode.
Yeah.
There are about 2 million views each and
then that's nothing compared to youtube
and youtube is nothing compared to the
audio.
So the audio is like five times that or
something.
Yeah.
So,
so that's,
yeah,
it's completely crazy.
No,
I haven't adjusted to it.
So I don't know.
I mean,
have You adjusted to your status?
I'm numb.
Yeah.
So what's it like when you think about
it?
You wake up in the morning and you
think,
okay,
I'm going to get a billion downloads
this year.
I don't think that.
I think I'm going to talk to Jordan
Peterson.
What do I want to talk about?
That's how I handle it.
It's exactly the same thing for the last
15 months.
This is what I've done.
Got up in the morning.
I've looked at like 25 things I have to
do in a mad rush before 7:00
at night.
I think I'm going to go through them and
I'm gonna concentrate on them,
do the best job I can.
then at 7:00
tonight I'm going to have a rest.
I'm going to take a look at what I have
to do tomorrow and I'm going to do the
same thing.
That's what I've been doing.
And then when I stand back a little bit,
like when it sort of dawns on me,
you know,
then it's disconcerting.
Like it's surreal.
I can'T figure it out.
I can't understand it.
But then I.
But there's no sense dwelling on that
because first of all,
I don't know how to conceptualize it.
I don't know why it's happening exactly.
Like I think what's happened is that two
things,
one is that I said it,
there was something I wouldn't do with
regards to this legislation and I meant
it.
I actually meant it.
I wasn't going to use those words under
legal compulsion period no matter what
it actually meant that.
So there was that.
But then I think the more relevant thing
is that I've been studying these old
stories,
these archetypal stories for a very long
period of time and they have power,
they really have power and they manifest
themselves everywhere.
They manifest themselves in movies and
in books.
I mean harry potter's a mythological
story and it made roland richer than the
queen of england.
You know,
these stories have power.
And I Was fortunate enough to study of
large number of people,
large number of scholars who knew what
that power was,
carl jung in particular,
and I could make it more accessible to
people.
And so that's a big part of it.
But what the overall significance of
that is?
Well,
I just,
it just leaves me speechless.
I mean this kathy newman things,
a good example.
And I mean,
so many things have happened.
I've,
I've got involved,
I've been in this scandal of some sort,
a serious scandal of some sort probably
every three weeks for a year and a half.
And they're things that are just.
Well,
the james damore thing is a good example
of that.
Like that's a big deal.
You know,
that that explosion that,
that,
that emerged around him and the court
case that's coming out of it,
it's a big deal.
And this thing with lindsay shepherd,
that was the worst scandal it ever hit a
canadian university.
And then there was all the protests and
then there was what happened with
channel four in the uk.
And it's like,
I don't know what to make of it.
I don't what what I'm trying to do is
have a good conversation when I come and
talk to somebody like you where we can
have a good conversation.
Try not to say anything stupid.
That's really what I'm trying to do is
to not say anything stupid or too
stupid.
Yeah,
well indeed it's been high stakes poker,
you know,
for.
It's not quite so bad now because
especially after what happened with
channel four and some journalists like
people have been trying to take me out
for quite a long time and it's not.
It isn't working so far actually.
You actually believe what you're saying
and it actually makes sense.
We're all,
you know,
that's a start.
It's not a bad start,
but it's rare in this world.
This is especially in these
ideologically charged times,
this toxic tribalism that we keep
bringing up.
It's well and I also decided like a long
time ago,
and I,
I think this runs through 12 rules for
life is well,
I believe that people's decisions tilt
the world towards heaven or hell.
I think there's no more accurate way of
describing the consequences of each of
your decisions.
Then that you face potential,
that's what you face.
The that's what you face in the world is
potential.
It's not material reality,
its potential,
and every decision you make you're
deciding whether you want to make the
world better or worse,
and if you like,
the ultimate better is heaven and the
ultimate worst is hell.
We know how to make the world into hail.
We we've done that multiple times.
Much of the 20th century was that.
It's like I looked at all that and I
thought,
okay,
I would rather that the world didn't
degenerate into hell and I understand
why people wanted to degenerate into
hell.
They're angry.
They're angry because they suffer,
they suffer unfairly,
and they suffer because people hurt
them,
and so they think this is a bad game.
I'm not going to help make it better.
I'm angry.
I'm going to make it worse.
Even that's what the columbine kids
didn't know.
That's what all the mass shooters do.
They say to hell with this.
I hate it.
They're going to make it more behind the
game.
They just want to flip the table over.
At worse than that,
they want to obliterate the game.
Yes,
and and they want to do it with as much
melyssa's possible just to obtain
revenge and I understand that,
but I decided a long time ago that I
would rather not play that game.
I think it.
I think that it's possible that we could
make the world better.
I really believe that.
Believe that too.
So I think while I'm trying to tell
people,
look,
there's more to you than you think.
There's more potential.
There's more than enough potential to go
around.
There's definite suffering and
malevolence in the world.
We could fix it.
You haven't got anything better to do.
That's a very big point,
that there's more potential to go around
more than enough.
More than people understand that we're
not going to run out of potential.
We're not.
And this idea of the famine thinking is
one of the reasons why people get upset
at other people's success.
They stink somehow under the this other
person's success.
Take something away from them.
Yup.
Yeah.
Well,
there's the other thing too,
is that I've realized that people
actually act like what they confronted
in the world is potential.
It's so funny because whatever potential
is.
It's not materially measurable,
but if you tell someone you're not
living up to your potential,
they go home.
Yeah.
Well,
I know that.
It's like,
well,
what is that potential that you're not
living up to?
And then When you say,
well,
there's potential in front of you,
you know that you can walk out on the
street and you go right or left or
straight ahead like that.
You're facing this thing that isn't
fully formed and you get to decide how
it's going to form and you can make it
better.
And so my question is like,
the world's a rough place.
There's no doubt about it.
It's a harsh place,
but my question is what would happen if
we start making it worse?
How good could it be if we stop making
it worse and I don't know if there's an
upper limit to that.
I get might be,
maybe we could make it really,
really,
really good.
Why not?
And we don't have anything better to do
than that.
It's like aim at heaven.
Start at home.
Amen.
Heaven tell the truth.
Let's see what the hell happens.
You know,
like it's,
it's,
it is the case clearly on the facts of
the matter.
In 20 years they wouldn't have to be a
single person in the world that was
hungry in 20 years.
We could get rid of the five biggest
diseases that currently plague the
planet.
We could straighten things up and god
only knows what things could be like
that.
Or we could let the whole thing
degenerate into hell.
So in each of us is making that decision
with each decision.
That's the other thing that I've
understood.
So take your choice.
You want hell or you want to heaven
p,
if you pick hell,
just remember you knew what you were
doing when you picked,
but nobody pixel.
Yeah.
To sort of let it slide.
The abbot,
they do it because they blind
themselves.
You know,
you know when you do it you say,
ah,
well you know,
I let that slide and then you.
And then you don't think about it.
It's like you could think about it,
you could think about it,
you could know,
but you don't let yourself know.
Is any of this all,
all the pressure and the scandal every
three weeks.
Is this a,
this is in weigh on you?
Is it,
is it difficult?
Uh,
how are you feeling like one new thing?
Stretch.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's like simultaneously the worst
possible thing in the best possible
thing that could happen.
Well,
financially it's been a boom,
right?
Yes.
It's.
Which says areas as an e.
Oh,
well I,
I mean the thing that I,
I shouldn't say this but I'm going to
because it's just so god damn funny.
I can't help but say it.
I figured out how to monetize social
justice warriors.
That is what it is.
I know.
It's so funny.
It just can't believe it either way.
It just,
every time.
I think that while it's just one of the
surreal circumstances that characterize
my life,
it's like I'm driving the social justice
activists in Canada mad because if they
let me speak then I get to speak and
then more people support me on patriot.
It's like,
that's annoying.
It's like god damn capitalists,
these make more money off this
ideological warfare.
It's like,
okay,
fine,
let's go protest.
It's they go protest me,
then that goes up on youtube and then my
patron account goes way up.
So it's like they don't know what to do.
And so one of the things that keep,
yeah,
they keep accusing me of,
uh,
like hauling in the loot and I think,
well look,
here's the situation guys.
I give away everything I do online for
free.
It's free and people are giving me
money.
They're just sending it to me.
I'm not twisting arm,
not even asking them for it.
Well,
I guess that's not exactlY right because
I set up the patron account,
but that's more complicated than it
looks that a lot of that was curiosity
and I thought,
well I could increase the production
quality of my online videos.
Well it was also the potential of you
being removed from the university there.
Yes.
Well that.
And that was real life pension.
Oh yeah.
Oh and yeah,
people wanted that.
Yeah.
They haven't stopped wanting that in
october when the lindsay shepherd
scandal broke and it looked so bad for
the left wing idiot logs,
like 200 university of toronto community
members signed a petition to get me
fired again and I was kind of upset
about that and this is what my life has
been like.
It's so.
My son came over that day and I said,
jesus julian,
you know,
like 200 people at the faculty member at
the university of toronto petitioned the
faculty association and then they send
in a petition to the administration to
get me fired.
It was the faculty association.
That's my union.
They didn't even contact me and julian
said,
don't worry about it data.
It was only 200 people and I thought
that's where my life is like it's like a
day where 200 people signed a petition
to get me fired as a professor.
My son can come in and say,
well,
that's not so bad.
It's like it's only 200 pets.
That's right.
It's so.
It's so surreal because you
say that online and look what's
happening and then the support would be
overwhelming.
It's a who knows how many people.
Well,
the administration.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Well,
in the administration at the university
of toronto,
like they didn't take.
They didn't take it seriously at all
called have me removed.
It didn't cause any.
Didn't even cause a ripple.
Now who were these 200 people and what
was their motivation?
Oh,
well they're hard to say what their
motivation was.
Not very happy about
see where they read the transcript or
listen to those recordings.
How could they possibly be against you
based on that?
Oh,
because they think that the people who
who,
who conducted the inquisition were.
Right.
Well,
that's madness.
Oh yes.
But look,
look,
I mean,
I mean this formally like 20 members of
pim,
lots and rambo count as faculty.
That was communications at wilfrid.
Laurier wrote a letter supporting them.
So that's why it's not an isolated
incident.
It's like,
no,
no.
They thought that what they were doing
was right.
It's massive stereo.
While there is an element of that,
that's for sure.
And there's certainly,
again,
I hate to bring this term up again,
but this toxic tribalism thing,
this like they are there supporting
their own and they understand that their
own ideologies had been completely
connected to the same type of group
thing that's going against lindsay
shepherd on that meeting when they tried
to paint her as a radical right winger
and data,
which she certainly isn't.
Of course.
No,
neither of You mean the whole thing is
ridiculous and you're not outright.
You're not a neo nazi,
you're not.
I've,
I've read a lot of crazy things about
you and knowing you personally seeing
this stuff.
I'm like,
this is,
this is A fascinating time to be live,
that's for sure.
That's for sure.
Yeah.
And it's been,
well,
it's been crazily.
Well I'm,
what would I say,
crazy stressful.
It's,
it's the best way to describe it is
surreal.
Like I'm,
it's like I stepped outside myself.
I can't,
I can't put this in a box.
I don't knoW what to make of it.
I don't know what to make of the channel
for interview.
You know?
It's like,
what the hell really?
It's,
it's,
it's crazy,
it's this,
these conversations are so limited by
what you were sayIng before that they're
trying to get this five minute soundbite
in and that's what television has
become.
It's a dying medium.
It doesn't make any sense.
It doesn't make any sense to sandwich
these commercials in every 15 minutes or
whatever they do.
None of it makes any sense.
It's an archaic way of communicating
ideas as
well.
Then I think that is part of it too,
is that like I happened to catch a
technological wave.
Well like you dId.
I mean their,
their television offers nothing over
youtube.
Nothing.
You offers everything that tv.
Yeah.
Well exactly.
And then there's no space requirements
on youtube so you don't have to do this,
twist the complex event into a short
sound bite and entertain everyone.
And it turns out too that there's this
huge audience online for actual content,
like just genuine conversation because
like one of the things that's happened
between you and I when,
when I've come down here is we've
actually had a conversation,
right?
We're trying to figure things out.
You know,
we've got our viewpoints and everything,
but we're basically an outline this and
there's a chapter in 12 rules for life
called assume that the person you're
talking to might know something you
don't,
which is like the formula for a good
conversation.
It's like there's a bunch of things I
don't understand about the world.
I mean that.
That's a big book.
Things I don't understand about the
world,
right?
That's a very thick book and I can come
in here and talk to you about what's
going on and hopefully we both emerged
with better understanding.
We're not tHe same people that we were
when we walked in and that's a good
thing.
And then we have those conversations
online and people can participate in
that and I'm trying to do that in my
lectures to like when I,
when I did this biblical series,
because that was another thing that was
so strange,
chose like imagine I walked into a,
like a venture capitalist organization.
I said,
look,
I want you guys to bank.
Roll me.
I'm going to do 15 lectures on the old
testament and I'm Going to try to
attract young men.
I'm going to rent a theater.
like they just laughed me out of there.
So could you imagine anything less
scalable than that?
So I did that.
I went ahead with it.
I rented the theater and then I walked
through these stories and I was learning
a lot because like I knew this first
stories in genesis up to the flood.
I knew them pretty well.
I knew kind of understood what they
meant,
but then all the stories from abraham
onward I had read them but I hadn't done
an detailed in depth analysis and so I
was learning a tremendous amount of
walking through those stories and they
had a big.
They'd had a big impact man and So I'm
going to do exodus soon because I want
to do that,
but it's just another example of how
surreal things have become,
but also the use the utility of a good
conversation.
Because like when I'm up on on
on the podium,
say lecturing,
I'm not exactly lecturing.
I'm trying to figure something out and
sharing that process with the audience,
which is so different than what is going
on in universities that is freaking
everybody out and see what's going on.
Is this indoctrination into this group
thing?
Yeah.
It's like,
here's what's right.
Memorize it.
Right.
It's like my lectures are more like,
well,
I don't know what's right.
Like here's some things I know and they
seem to be working in.
Here's how I use those tools to dig it,
this story and here's what it might mean
and this is what I got from it and been
here some universal truths about human
beings that that seemed to be,
and then I've tried to explore that.
It's like,
well,
should we believe this?
Should we?
Like when abraham in the abrahamic
story,
for example,
I mean abraham was an old guy and he's
basically lived in his mom's basement.
That's really the beginning of the story
and he gets a call to adventure.
you know,
god says,
will get,
get,
get away from your family and your can
get out there in the world.
It's the call to adventure.
thank.
Okay,
fine.
That's a heroic motif,
but then abraham goes out and the first
thing he encounters is like tyranny and
starvation and then a bunch of guys who
want to steal his wife,
so it's,
it's been entertaining to take those
stories apart and to see why they're
foundational because they are
foundational and they're not mirror
ignorance that what whatever they are.
Ignorance.
Superstition is not the right categorY.
How has this changed your classrooms?
Well,
I haven't gone back teaching since all
of this hit because when diD you stop
teaching?
Oh,
well.
Oh no,
I guess that's not true.
That's not true.
I taught from january to may of 2016.
Well,
first way it,
it changed.
It was that I was like so,
so shell shocked when I went to to teach
last january that and I was really sick.
Like I've been really sick this year.
I had like last january,
jesus.
It was just dismal.
I wouldn't have worst wish that on my
worst enemy.
I had three weeks where I didn't sleep a
wink.
He try that.
That's really entertaining for one long
day of misery.
that's three weeks long.
What kind of a an illness?
It looks like an auto immune disorder.
Do you think this is because of stress?
No,
I don't.
You don't think it's connected at all?
Yeah,
I think it probably made it worse,
but no.
It's something that I battled with for a
long time and it's something that really
both my wife and I have autoimmune
illness and my daughter got what on?
I don't know exactly what it is.
I don't know what it is in my daughter.
Manifest.
Yes.
That's what's fixed.
What fixed it?
All I eat is meat and greens.
That's it.
No juice?
No.
No vegetables,
no carbohydrates.
Meet grades.
That's it.
And that fixed it.
That seems to have fixed.
It fixes so many people.
If you've listened to the podcast,
I've done that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
I've been following them because my
daughter has blog to called don't eat
that and my daughter had a terrible
autoimmune disorder.
It was awful.
I detail that out in chapter 12.
She had 38 affected joints and she had
her hip and her ankle replacement.
She was 16.
Jesus,
so she walked around on two broken legs
for a year and unscrewed,
creating pain.
She goes on extremely high doses of
opiates and so she was addicted to
opiates,
which she like.
She just wants.
She had her surgery.
She just went off them cold Turkey and
suffered through the withdrawal for two
months and compared to what she had been
through,
that was nothing like what she went
through.
Man knew it was dreadful and that was
just the surface of it.
Like that was only the beginning of her
illness.
She had all sorts of other things that
were worse than that and so and we
figured she was probably going to die by
the time she was 30 because my cousin's
daughter had a similar autoimmune
problem and she died when she was 30,
so it was bloody dreadful,
but she figured out at one point that it
was associated with diet and then she
went on a radically restrictive diet and
she christ she,
she was on antidepressants.
She's not.
She had take ritalin to stay awake.
She can only stay awake about six hours
a day and she had to take high doses of
ritalin.
Distilling she,
what is this autoimmune disease.
While she had,
her diagnosis was rheumatoid arthritis,
but she didn't have the blood markers
for it,
but she had all the other symptoms.
Anyway,
she,
she figured out this restrictive diet.
She only ate chicken and broccoli for
about two months and almost all her
symptoms went away and she's pretty much
symptom free now,
which is,
it's a complete miracle and she
convinced me to try this diet about a
year and a half ago,
and so I lost seven pounds a month for
seven months.
That was the first thing,
which was just bloody amazing.
Yeah,
it was unbelievable.
It was unbelievable.
I couldn't believe it.
You know,
you was your diet rich and refined
carbohydrates before that,
rich or not rich enough,
you know,
um,
pastas and bread,
bread,
bread in particular,
a lot of bread.
So the first thing that happened was a
quit snoring.
That happened immediately.
Took,
took one week and I was snoring quite
badly.
That.
So that disappeared in a week.
And that was amazing.
I thought,
oh,
that's interesting.
And then I had gastric reflux disorder
that went away.
And then I lost seven pounds the first
mOnth.
I thought,
whoa,
that's a lot.
Seven pounds.
I had psoriasis that went away.
I had floaters in my right eye,
which is also an autoimmune problem that
went away.
I have had gum disease for 30 years.
That went away.
That's amazing.
I'm 55,
like my gum disease went away.
It's ridiculous.
So I figured all that out my life in the
last year.
It was so,
so strange because I'd get up in the
morning and I'd think,
god,
all these bloody scandalous things are
happening around me and I have to deal
with that.
And then I think I need a break,
but I can't eat anything.
I can't eat anything because if I ate
the wrong thing it would knock me out
for a month.
So I was trying to figure out what the
hell was wrong,
my diet.
And I was feeding wretched.
And so it was like,
if I was like wolves at the backdoor and
crocodiles at the front door,
something like that.
So,
but,
but whatever,
like I'm down to the same weight I was
when I was 25.
Wow.
Yeah.
No kidding.
And I've got lots of energy.
I wake up in the morning and I wake up.
That's never happened to me in my whole
life.
I've always had to have a shower,
like took me an hour to wake up my whole
life.
That's gone.
I'm not hungry.
I don't have hyperglycemia.
I've lots of energy.
Um,
I can't eat anything but.
So I can't go out for dinner and then
you can't eat nonsense you can eat.
I mean I'm on the same diet,
eat meat and greens.
I don't have a disorder like you did in
the same regard.
But I take a day where I have a cheat
day.
No,
I don't even do it every week we'll have
a cheeseburger or something like that.
Yeah.
But for the most part,
that's the diet that I follow as well.
Yep.
Well,
for some people it seems like,
like,
uh,
well from massive amount of people,
well I think for far more people than we
knew.
I think people are carbohydrate
poisoning themselves.
Like they can't believe.
Yes.
And along with all the other things that
go along with it,
insulin,
the blood sugar's not good cholesterol
in this,
this idea that cholesterol and saturated
fat are the problems that people are
experienCing.
It's not true.
Nope.
The real problem is sugar and
cholesterol has been demonized.
I'm sure you read the article New York
times or the sugar industry paid off
scientists to lie about the results.
yep.
Yep.
Well,
I know too that to food scientists in
the uk resigned about three years ago.
They were,
they were part and parcel of the
organization that it pRoduced.
The food pyramid.
They said it was the worst public health
disaster the last 40 years.
It's pretty much got it backwards and
you look around,
you know,
you drive through the u.
S it's really obvious in the us is
people are overweight.
Like matt,
like,
oh yeah.
Like it's crazy.
It's crazy ridiculous.
go to disneyland.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's insane.
It is,
but you know,
and the reason is,
as far as I can tell,
the reason is is that they're,
they're poisoning themselves with
carbohydrates.
That's what it looks like.
And the thought process is so out of,
out of whack.
I retweeted an article today from nina
thai shorts.
She,
she tweeted it about this trend of
eating only egg whites and how terrible
it is for you.
It's a,
it's a health disaster and this idea
that cholesterol from the egg yolk is
bad for you.
it's one of the most important things
you can eat is it's.
And then weightwatchers is adjusted.
See it goes weightwatchers died program.
Now adjust the pro their protocol and
they say that eat all the eggs you want.
It is now a zero point food,
which is fucking incredible.
Yeah.
So.
And the way I don't get hungry as I eat
a lot of oil,
like a lot of old oil.
Yes.
So that keeps that.
So you're basically burning fat.
You're under like a ketogenic diet and
it seems to be well and that was
complex.
That would have been complicated enough
to keep me occupied for the laSt two
years,
especially sorting it out with my
daughter because she.
Well,
that was quite the bloody nightmare.
I can tell you.
It was really something,
but I can't believe she figured it out.
It's amazing.
It is amazing.
And she's really.
She's in pretty damn good shape.
She just had a baby five months ago,
so that was two.
Yeah,
we're,
we're stunned.
Man.
Were stunned because like it was,
it was rough.
Well,
she sounds like an incredibly extreme is
quite the tough cookie.
That girl sounds like a.
Yeah.
Many people are experiencing the same
revelation that their diet is what I was
tired all the time.
I hit a.
I mean I was always very,
very active so I stayed lean because of
my physical activity.
But by the end of the day I need a nap.
I would always take a nap befoRe I'd go
to jujitsu.
I was like,
I have to take a nap or I can't train
because of carbohydrates boat two hours
a day and now I don't nap at all.
Me too.
Same thing.
That's not exactly true when I've been
zooming around,
I take like two minute naps when I'm in
the airport or whatever,
but that's also,
you're probably not getting enough
sleep,
right.
big difference.
Exactly.
So yeah,
it's been,
it's been remarkable.
So.
So why did you stop teaching?
Oh,
well I took a sabbatical because of all
this.
Yeah,
well I told the.
I told my department chair said,
look,
I had a sabbatical coming up next year.
I said,
look,
you know,
there's too much going on.
It'll be better if I take the sabbatical
this year then I can concentrate on my
teaching next year.
So you take the entire year off.
Yeah.
So you're about eight months in,
is that correct?
Yeah,
well,
and I always teach from,
I put all my courses from january to
march.
I teach all of them in the same semester
and that enabled me to concentrate on my
research for the rest of the time and so
technically I'll be going back teaching
in january of 2019.
Technically.
Technically you're not convinced.
Well,
I can't think a year ahead at the
moment.
I don't know what the hell's going on.
I'm not going to go back and teach the
same way because see at some point the
technological transformation means you
have to approach things differently.
And so now if I do a lecture online,
whatever the lecture happens to be,
I can get 150,000
people to watch it.
That's minimum.
So the first question would be,
well why would I teach 300 people when I
can teach 150,000?
That's just stupid,
right?
Who would do that?
Those same 300 people are also have
access to the 50.
Exactly.
That's right.
That's exactly it.
And the next thing is,
well I taped my maps of meaning class
and my personality class for three years
running.
It's like it's there.
Well I could do it again,
but why it's taped.
I would rather lecture about new things.
So that's what I did this year.
I did this biblical series which I
hadn't done before,
but now if I'm going to lecture again,
I'm going to lecture about different
things because because the technology
has transformed the landscape.
We're not in 1990 anymore,
not even a little bit.
Right,
so,
and this is something that I brought up
to bret weinstein and I'm hoping he
falls along the same line.
Same bet.
Weinstein,
not steen.
I make that mistake often.
Sorry brett,
but same thing,
brilliant guy,
restricted by his university,
big scandal leaves and I'm hoping he
follows the same path because he has so
much to offer and he has so much to
offer for anybody who can get online.
One of the things that's really fun
about youtube that and having my
lectures on youtube,
is that the only reason people watch
them is one reason is because they want
to learn.
That's it,
and so it's.
You might think,
well,
where is the university?
Well,
the university is where people wAnt to
learn.
It's like,
okay,
well youtube is the university because
there's hundreds of thousands of people
on youtube,
maybe millions who just want to learn.
It's like,
fine,
I'm an educator.
I'll talk to people who want to learn
because if you're an educator,
that's what you do.
Is that most effectively done in the
universities?
Not self.
Evidently,
and so now I'm trying to figure this
out,
you know,
like I like my job at the univerSity on
uft has treated me well apart from this
scandal thing,
but they were kind of taken aback by
they didn't know what to do about that,
you know,
it was a new law and wHen I made the
video criticizing bill c 16,
I said,
I think that making this video is
probably illegal in and of itself.
Was there controversial moments in your
career before that?
No.
Wow.
No,
I mean it surprised me because I've
always,
I would say that the content of my
lectures has been a typical,
but it's been a typical in a Good way.
Like the student responds to my lectures
has always been extremely good,
extremely good.
I'm always surprised that I was able to
teach what I'm teaching because I always
thought that it was like insanely
revolutionary,
but it was revolutionary in a really,
like in a scholarly way,
you know,
like I'm a careful scientist,
I'm a careful thinker.
I think things all the way through to
the bottom and I'm really self critical.
Like when I wrote maps of meaning,
which was my first book,
I suspect I rewrote every sentence at
least 15 times.
It's probably more than that and I
really literally mean rewrite it.
So I take the sentence out of the
paragraph,
put it in another document,
right,
like 10 variants of the sentence,
and then pick the one that was best.
And I did that.
Like it took me 15 years to write.
I did that over and over and over.
And so what I was,
I'd write a sentence and then I'd think,
okay,
have I got all the words,
write every single word.
Is that the proper words?
The proper phrase is the proper
sentence.
Do I believe that this sentence is true?
Then I'd think of 10 ways I can attack
it and see if I could break it apart and
find out what it was wrong and only kept
the ones that I couldn't destroy and
like I was going out full force to
destroy them because I wanted to come up
with a,
you know,
come on,
I want it to produce a book that I could
not break no matter what.
I did and so I spent 15 years on that
now.
That was the basis,
what's the basis for 12 rules for life.
It's been the basis for all the lectures
I've done and so forth and like I can't
see where it's wrong and mostly what I
was trying to do is to see where it was
wrong and I can't get underneath it.
I can't break it.
That's what's so fascinating to me about
all this stuff and not to.
Not to overly exaggerate the
significance of this,
but just to be completely honest about
it.
You're the right guy for the job and
it's sort of found you.
It's real weird because there's not a
lot of people that are that meticulous
about their thoughts and about their
work and about their writing and about.
They're criticizing their own ideas to
the point where they break them down,
try to break them,
trying to tell them apart.
I had a big problem,
so when I.
When I started to write maps of meaning,
I thought,
okay,
what's the situation?
This is the cold war.
We've divided into two arm tribal camps
and we've decided that settling the
difference between us is worth risking
being itself.
We could,
we could drive everything into
extinction.
We're willing to take that chance.
It's like what the hell is going on?
So I wanted to know two things,
what was truly driving the tribalism of
the cold war,
including it's including the generation
of that vast nuclear arsenal because
that just seemed to me to be insanity
taken to the final pinnacle.
So I wanted to know that and I wanted to
know,
okay,
having figured out why that's happening,
what could be done about it so it would
stop and at the same time I was also
studying what had happened in auschwitz
and with the nazis and all of that and
so it was a very serious problem and I
actually wanted to have the answer,
actually wanted the answer.
I didn't want to write an interesting
book about it.
It wasn't even that I wanted to write a
book.
Exactly.
It was just that writing a book was the
best way to figure out the problem
because it's really writing a book is so
rigorous,
you know,
cause you think,
but you can only remember so much.
You have to write it down because then
you can remember way more and you can.
Right.
And then the next day you can go back
and think,
okay,
I'm going to take that goddamn argument
apart.
I'm going to see if there's anything
about it this week.
And so.
And I think I did figure it out.
I think I did figure it out.
So.
And then when I,
when I.
Well,
and then I started lecturing about it
and the lectures were always
unbelievably well regarded.
Like people,
the kids in the classes would always
write for the evaluations.
At the end of the year,
80 percent of them would say,
and this happened for 20 years,
say this class changed everything about
the way I look at the world.
It's like,
yeah,
that's what happened to me too.
And I wrote that book.
It's like I didn't think the same way at
all when I was done.
I started to understand what these
ancient stories meant.
It was like shocking.
Never recovered from it.
Well listen,
you're out of time.
Thank you.
Always 12 rules for life.
An antidote to chaos.
Jordan peterson.
I made a.
I made a discount for your viewers again
for the future authoring program.
Okay.
So what do they have to do?
Rogan.
Just use rogan and how do they get.
Get to the website.
[inaudible] dot com.
Okay.
Yep.
And
I'll send you a link for that.
Thanks a lot to say and also thanks for
everything really.
You were the portal into this weird
world that I'm in and people say that
all the time.
They come up and say,
look,
I heard about you on joe rogan spike in
like thousands of people have told me
that.
So it's been an honor.
I appreciate it,
sir.
Thank you.
You bet.